GET STARTED WE ARE WAITING FOR-
OTHER MEMBERS TO COME THERE'S A
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES ARE BEING
HEARD ONE- LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
EDUCATION THAT WE MIGHT HAVE TO
STEP OUT TO PRESENT. ON
ANOTHER- THE BILL BUT I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
JOINING US I'M HERE TODAY. AND
BEFORE WE GET STARTED I WANTED
TO RECOGNIZE THE TRAVEL-
AFFILIATIONS OF THE LAND- THAT
WERE AND THAT'S THE- ME WHAT
THE NISSEN AND THE BOTTOM LINE
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA WE
WANT T RECOGNIZE THOSE TRIBAL-
GROUPS FROM. THIS AREA BEFORE
WE STARTED SO LET'S GIVE THE
RECOGNITION TO THOSE GROUPS ARE
HERE. CALIFORNIA'S TREATMENT OF
ITS TRAVEL PEOPLE IS A LONG
HISTORY OF INJUSTICE THAT
INCLUDES GENOCIDE. YET I AM
HEARTENED AT THE LAST LAST JUNE
THE GOVERNOR MOVED FORWARD WITH
ANNOUNCING ATROCITIES IN
GENOCIDES TOWARDS THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AND CONTINUES
TO SHOW THAT COMMITMENT BY
INCLUDING- WITHIN THE BUDGET OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AREAS
THAT CONTINUE TO MOVE TRIBAL
ISSUES FORWARD. AND WITH THAT
NEW PATH BEGINS WITH EDUCATION
EDUCATION THAT INVOLVES CANDID
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE
FROM PHILLY RECOGNIZE TO NON
RECOGNIZED TO CALIFORNIA INDIAN
PEOPLE AS A WHOLE. IS SO THIS
TAKES TIME TIME TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THESE TYPES OF HEARINGS TO
EDUCATE THE LEGISLATION AT THE
LEGISLATORS AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ON THE PAST
HISTORIES THAT WAS PERPETRATED
AGAINST CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. IN
THAT NEW RELATIONSHIP EVERY
OURS INCLUSION AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE HISTORY
NOT ONLY IN GENERAL BUT ALSO OF
DIFFERENCES AMONG THE VARIOUS
DEFINITIONS WITHIN THE TRIBES
AND THEIR HISTORY. TODAY
SPEAKERS WILL HELP TO MOVE THAT
PATH FORWARD. THIS IS OUR FIRST
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN AFFAIRS FOR
THIS FOR THIS SESSION AND WITH
US TODAY AND IN THE AGENDA.
WE'RE GONNA BE TACKLING ISSUES.
THE DEAL WITH CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
HISTORY FEDERAL STATE
RECOGNITION. WE'RE ALSO GONNA
LOOK AT NON PHILLY RECOGNIZED
AND HOW THAT BECAME AN ISSUE IN
THE IMPACTS ALL THESE HAVE A
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY DEAR TO
THE NUCLEUS OF THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE AND THAT'S THE
PRESERVATION AND THE CULTURE OF
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE OUT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN WE
ENGAGE WITH NATIVE AMERICAN.
REMAINS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE THE
ISSUES THAT SELECT COMMITTEE
WILL BE ADDRESSING HERE TODAY.
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE HERE WITH
US ASSEMBLY MEMBER TODD GLORIA.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS OUR KNOWLEDGE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD GLORIA. BECAUSE WE
WANT TO KNOW HOW MUCH ONE THANK
YOU SIR FOR SCHEDULING THIS
AGREES MANY FIRST PLACE
PREVIOUS OVERLY INNER CITY
AREAS START STOP EATING
DISORDER BACK BASE TO BE
IMPATIENT ALRIGHT OFFICE EITHER
I. HAVE A IF THIS WOULD BE A
LITTLE BIT TIME THOSE ARE FULL
TIME TO GO ON AND ON A PART OF
THE B. HERE REPRESENT IS DONE
FAR DATE IF YOU CAN- JUST
THINKING GET IS CHAIR AT YOU
AND I ARE CONCERNED- AND ALSO
THE SUITABLE TIME UNDER THE
HOUSE OF THE LEGISLATURE OF
TENS OF. THE BOARDS OF
REPRESENTATION- BOTH IN AND
OUTSIDE OF THE. OFFICE TO THE-
NEXT DAY. THANK YOU. THE
HISTORIC CHANGES THAT NOT ONLY
HAVE HAPPENED A HEARING
CALIFORNIA ACROSS WHAT WE KNOW
AS THE UNITED STATES BUT
REALLY. ACROSS ALL OF TURTLE
ISLAND SO I APPRECIATE BEING ON
THIS COMMITTEE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THE PRESENTATIONS FOR TODAY.
THANK YOU ALSO REMEMBER MEDINA.
THANK YOU FIRST I WANT TO ALSO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR. HAVING
THIS HEARING- AS THE CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THE ISSUE OF
THE REMAINS- THE MOST
SPECIFICALLY AT UC BERKELEY. IS
AN ISSUE THAT EFFORT STILL
ONGOING OF MUCH CONCERN TO
MYSELF. AS IT IS TO THE REGIONS
SO I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE
THIS AFTERNOON LOOK FORWARD TO
THE PRESENTATIONS. AND THANK
YOU AGAIN TO THE CHAIR FOR
HAVING THIS YEAR. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND OUR FIRST
SPEAKERS YOU CAN MAKE YOUR WAY
UP TO THE DESK HERE. IS GONNA
BE CATCH A WRESTLING BALDING
SHE'S THE ASSISTANT PROFESSOR.
AND DEPARTMENT CHAIR OF NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDIES AT HOME WILL
STATE UNIVERSITY. AND PUBLISH
CREATIVE- WRITER AND BLOGGER.
CHAU SPEAK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL HISTORY.
WELL THANK YOU AND- ORIGINALLY
FAMILY WE HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT
FOR YOU AND YOUR FAMILY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING ME
TODAY- HEY YOUNG CATCHER WAS
INVOLVED THE A WHOLE YET KING
AT AND I'VE TAKEN A OCT TAKE
THE AFTER A NOCTURNAL CLICK.
OFF TODAY SO I'M DOCTOR CATCH
WRESTLING BALDY I AM WHO BY
AMERICAN CREDIT FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND ROLLED IN THE
WHO THE VALLEY TRIBE- AND WHEN
I INTRODUCED MYSELF I ALSO SAY
I'M KENYON ON WHICH IS THE WHO
BY WAY OF SAYING. I'M A PERSON
I'M A HUMAN BEING- BUT ACTUALLY
MEANS I'M A CORN EITHER.
BECAUSE WE SAID THAT IF YOU
WANTED TO BE A HUMAN BEING YOU
HAD TO EAT ACORNS- I ACTUALLY.
GET TO CHEAT A LITTLE BIT
TODAY- THEY ASKED ME TO COME
AND SPEAK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND- SHOW UP
FIRST A SHORT VIDEO THAT WE
CREATED A BUT I'M WHAT STATE AS
PART OF THE PLACE BASED
LEARNING COMMUNITIES THAT WE
WORK WITH. A COUPLE STATE WE'RE
DOING SOME REALLY AMAZING
THINGS WITH PLACE BASED
LEARNING AND THERE ARE NUMBER
FRESHMAN IN THE SCIENCES WHO
COME IN AND THEIR FIRST YEAR
AND NOW BECAUSE OF THE WORK
WE'VE BEEN DOING WITH THE
SCIENCE DEPARTMENTS. AND THE
SCIENCE FRESHMAN NOW I'LL TAKE
A NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES
WORSE. PART OF- LEARNING ABOUT
THE SCIENCES ESPECIALLY WITH
LIKE A LOT OUT. AND SO THE
SPEECH. THAT TEXT FOR
UNDERSTANDING OF ARMENIAN
HISTORY WHEN THEY COME IN-
THEIR FRESHMAN YEAR THEY HAVE
MORE OF AN IDEA OF WHAT THEY'RE
SORT OF WORRIED ABOUT AND-
LEARNING OF. CALIFORNIANS
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT
WAS THE DATE. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A POPULOUS PLACE IS
HOME RIGHT NOW TO A HUNDRED AND
NINE TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN TRIBES
BUT BACK THEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRIBES EVERYWHERE. THERE
IS NO EMPTY SPACE OF WILDERNESS
THAT EXISTS IN THIS PLACE THAT
WE CURRENTLY CALL CALIFORNIA.
THE WAY YOU KNOW THAT THEY WERE
CALIFORNIA INDIANS EVERYWHERE.
IS THAT EVERY PLACE HAD A NAME.
THERE WAS NOT MOUNT TEN OR A
FIELD OR REGION THAT THERE
WASN'T A TRIBE WHO HAD ALREADY.
FOR THE SCIENCES I THINK THAT
THE LAND BRIDGE THERE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN SORT OF A FIRST
POINT OF. KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
NATIVE PEOPLE. BUT THERE ARE
MANY STUDIES THAT HAVE SHOWN
THAT THERE WERE AS HUMANS IN
THIS SIDE OF THE AMERICAS. OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
WHICH WOULD MEAN THAT. THAT IS
AROUND THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME
IN WHICH THEY SAY PEOPLE WERE
SORT OF FIRST LEAVING AFRICA.
AND SO AND WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE
TO COMPLICATE HOW THEY
UNDERSTAND WHO WE ARE AS
INDIGENOUS PEOPLES HERE WHAT WE
SAY IS WERE FROM THIS PLACE.
THAT'S A REALLY TRUE BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE WE ARE A PART OF
THE LAND AND THE LAND IS US AND
WE- DIDN'T MIGRATE FROM SOME
OTHER PLACE WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
THERE. WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN A PART
OF OUR LAND. AND NOT ABOVE IT
HELLO IT BUT- EQUAL TO AND WE
HAVE A ROLL. BAR RULES COME
FROM. THAT ENGAGEMENT COME
FROM. SEEING WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO MAKE THINGS THE BEST
WAY THEY CAN. ALL THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES THEY THINK.
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE HERE BUT
THEY'RE NOT REALLY DOING MUCH
WITH THE SPACE THERE'S- SO MUCH
EVIDENCE OF AGRICULTURE THERE'S
EVIDENCE OF LARGE AREAS IN
WHICH THEY'RE TENDING TO
THERE'S EVIDENCE OF WAYS IN
WHICH THEY'RE SHAPING WHAT WE
NOW THINK OF. THE NATURAL
LANDSCAPE. AND THEN
CONVERSATION HAPPENS. DOLLARS
THEY CALL IT INVASION. SO WE'RE
BEING INVADED. WHEN CAN VERY-
IS FIRST ON ONE OF HIS SHIPS
AND FIFTEEN HUNDREDS BURNING OF
THE LAND IS WHAT ACTUALLY GAVE
AWAY PEOPLE ON THAT LAND THAT
WAS LIKE THE FIRST THING THAT
YOU KNOW COLONIZER SALAS OR
TRADITIONAL. LANDS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THREE WEEKS OF
DESTRUCTION FROM THE START OF
THESE WAVES. THERE'S NOT REALLY
A TIME PERIOD IN WHICH
CALIFORNIA INDIANS CAN RECOVER
FROM WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM.
THE FIRST WAVE OF DESTRUCTION
IS THE SPANISH MISSION SYSTEM.
THE BILL THE FIRST MISSION AND
SAN DIEGO. THERE'S TWENTY ONE
MISSIONS THAT THEY BUILD IN
TOTAL DISS FATHER IN A PRESS
ERA AND THEY'RE BRINGING PEOPLE
INTO THE MISSIONS IN THE HOPES
THAT THEY CAN CREATE THIS LABOR
FORCE TO BE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
THIS. EXTENSION OF SPAIN.
MISSION SYSTEM IS EFFECTIVELY
ENSLAVEMENT SYSTEM OF
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE. THAT
MISSIONARIES BRING ALONG WITH
THEM SPANISH SOLDIERS THE
SOLDIERS. ARE WRITTEN ABOUT IN
THESE RECORDS AS- BEING
PERPETRATORS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE. NOT ONLY AGAINST
WOMEN BUT ALSO CHILDREN.
UNIVERSE ARE ACTUALLY TALKED
ABOUT THAT IN HIS JOURNAL LIKE
THEY'RE SEXUALLY ASSAULTING
WOMEN AND CHILDREN IN FRONT OF
PEOPLE. AND WHEN PEOPLE TRY TO
STOP THEM THEY GET SHOT I MEAN
IT'S A VERY VIOLENT TYPE OF
SITUATION. THE MISSION I'M SORT
OF STOPS AROUND SAN FRANCISCO
SO UP HERE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT
US IS WE WERE CONTACTED
RELATIVELY LATE. IN THAT SORT
OF COLONIZATION CYCLE. WAIT I
CONTACT WITH THEM EXPLORE SO
WOULD COME THROUGH PEOPLE THAT
WERE LOOKING MOSTLY FOR GOLD
AND AT A POINT THEY FIND GOLD
AND THIS IS WHERE YOU GET THE
SORT OF LIKE MASSIVE INFLUX OF
THE GOLD RUSH. AND IT JUST CAME
LIKE OVERNIGHT AND IT CAME IN
HARD. AND LIFE JUST CHANGED
DRASTICALLY IN JUST IMMEDIATELY
AND A LOT OF WAYS FOR
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. THEY'RE NOT
HERE SO THAT THEY CAN SET UP A
COLONY OR SO THAT THEY CAN
ESTABLISH A LABOR FORCE THEY
WANT GOALS THEY WILL KILL
WHOEVER IS IN THE WAY THEY WILL
TAKE A PART WHATEVER NEEDS TO
BE TAKEN APART. THEY'LL DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES. THE THING
ABOUT THE GOLD RUSH THAT P. O.
THINK ABOUT IS THAT IT WAS
ACTUALLY AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DESTRUCTION AS WELL. AND ON TOP
OF THAT THEY ARE SETTING UP A
POLITICAL SYSTEM AND THE STATE
SSTEM OF LAWS AND GOVERNANCE
THAT WILL LEGALIZE THE GENOCIDE
THAT THEY WANT TO COMMIT
AGAINST CALIFORNIA EIGHTEEN
PEOPLE. OUR FIRST LOOK PETER
BURNETT. ALL THIS HUGE
POPULATION OF INDIANS AND STATE
AND SO HE'S THE ONE THAT YOU
KNOW CHARGE THE WAR OF
EXTERMINATION CALIFORNIANS.
THEN WE LOST YOU KNOW PROBABLY
AROUND 80% OF OUR TOTAL
POPULATION IT IS JUST A SHORT
PERIOD OF YEARS. THERE IS SAYS
ONE OF THE RESOURCES YOU WANTED
WHAT WOULD MAKE HIM RICH
FASTER. IS TO ASKING THE TRIBE
TO HELP MORE SYSTEM THE CIVIL
SINCE TRY PRIME WILL JUST GET
TO THIS REGIS AND WEBER I'M OUT
WE'RE GONNA MASSACRE WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR THE FOR OURSELVES.
EACH REGION OF CALIFORNIA IS
ALLOWED TO SET THEIR OWN SORT
OF WHAT ARE WE GONNAPAY FOR
SCALP OR HEAD. BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT ADVERTISEMENT. WHAT YOU
SEE IS THAT THEIR ADVERTISING
THEM AND THINGS LIKE FIVE
DOLLARS A HEAD AND TWENTY FIVE
CENTS PER SCALP. THE FIRST YEAR
THAT THEY DO THIS. THEY PAY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAYS THAT IT HAS
PAID ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
KILLING ANY PEOPLE THE SECOND
YEAR THEY DO IT IT'S ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN THIS REGION
EVERY SINGLE TRIBE IN THIS
REGION WOULD HAVE SOME KIND OF
STORIES ABOUT THE VIOLENCE THAT
CAME OUT OF THE GOLD RUSH. MY
GREAT GRANDFATHER HINO HIS HIS
FAMILY IS FROM CREDIT COUNTRY.
HIS GREAT UNCLE HAD. HIS MOM
HAD LIVED TO THE GOLD RUSH AND
HE WAS BORN SORT OF LIKE AT THE
TAIL END OF THIS PERIOD OF
TIME. AND HE WOULD ALWAYS SAY
TO MY MOTHER. IN REMEMBER
GRANDDAUGHTER- YOUR HERE
BECAUSE SOME MINOR WAS A BAD
SHOT. LIKE THAT'S HOW CLOSE IT
IS TO WHO WE ARE. WHEN WATER
CONTENT GET ABOUT ALL IN
RELATION TO FORGET ABOUT ALL
THE SCIENCES AND WE HAD TO
FORGET ABOUT ALL THE FALL LOSS
OF THESE WE HAD TO BRING IT
ABOUT EVERYTHING. THOSE
INGRAINED PROS FOR THOUSANDS OF
YEARS. TWO SHATTERED EXISTENCE
.
THIS IS TAKING HIS FROM YOUR
FAMILY AND TAKE ON BOARDING
SCHOOLS. AND THIS IN THE YOU
WERE NOT A PRACTITIONER
CULTURES YOU'RE NOT TO. FRAZIER
TRADITIONS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
PRACTICE YOU KNOW I HATE TO SAY
THIS WITH THE WHITE MAN'S
RELIGION YEAR YOU WERE GOING TO
CHRISTIANIZE YOU YOU'RE GOING
TO FOLLOW OUR GUIDE. I KNOW
NUMBER PRODUCT OF FOR
SIMULATION. I KNOW I WAS
STRIPPED OF. SOME OF THEM
SMARTEST INFORMATION A HUMAN
BEING COULD HAVE. I KNOW I
DON'T HAVE THAT NOW. I KNOW
IT'S ATTAINABLE OVER TIME. AND
WE'RE ON THE RIGHT PATH.
THERE'S ALL THESE GREAT MOMENTS
OF NATIVE PEOPLE MAKING SURE
THAT THEY WERE TRYING TO HOLD
ON TO THINGS LIKE FIGHTING BACK
AND MAKING PLANS FOR THE FUTURE.
IT'S PALPABLE IN HUMBLE COUNTY.
AMERICAN ESPECIALLY WE HAVE
SOME ISRAELI TRIES WERE PUT
THROUGH A LOT IT WASN'T JUST
THE WE ASKED IT WAS HERE- BUT
YEAH. WE'RE ALL PUT THROUGH A
LOT DURING THE EARLY YEARS.
HERE WE ARE GROWING. ROOM
STRONGER NATIONS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER AND WITH EACH OTHER.
TO CREATE A POSITIVE THING. AND
NOT ONLY LESS WORKING WITH EACH
OTHER SISTER TRIES WE'RE
WORKING WITH CITIES THE
GOVERNMENT SAYS AROUND US THE
SCHOOLS AGES YOU. TO MAKE THIS
MORE POSITIVE. HUMBLE STATE
UNIVERSITY IS WITHIN THE
ABORIGINAL TERRITORY OF THE WE
ARE PEOPLE AND THEN WE HAVE
SEVERAL OTHER LARGE TRIBES
AROUND HERE THE THREE LARGEST
IN CALIFORNIA THE COUNTRY THE
IRAQ IN THE LOOP ON. SO BEING
THAT WE ARE IN THE BACKYARD OF
THREE OF THE LARGEST TRIBES WE
CAN DRAW AND PARTNER WITH SOME
OF OUR LOCAL TRIBES. TO BRING
THAT EXTRA EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT TO OUR STEM AND
NATURAL RESOURCE. HERE THE
INDIAN NATURAL RESOURCE SCIENCE
AND ENGINEERING PROGRAM AND
DIVERSITY INSTEAD WE GO BY
INTERCEPT PLUS. OUR SERVICES
GENERALLY PROVIDE NAVIGATIONAL
SUGGESTIONS TO STUDENTS
ASSISTING THEM NAVIGATE THE
COLLEGE OF NATURAL RESOURCES
AND SCIENCES. WE OFTEN OR IN
REACHING THAT EXPERIENCEWITH
EXTRA CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES
COMING FROM- INDIGENOUS
PERSPECTIVE SO BRING IT UP OUR
ANCESTORS PRACTICES AND
TECHNIQUES OF MANAGING
LANDSCAPES MELDING THEM MORE
BREEDING THEM IN WITH THE
SCIENTIFIC METHOD IN INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES. IN NATIVE STUDIES
FOR DOING A SORT OF BROAD
SPECTRUM OF WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
LEARN FROM INDIGENOUS PEOPLES
AND CULTURES AND KNOWLEDGE IS
SO THAT WE CAN BUILD A BETTER
WORLD BUILD A BETTER WAY OF
KNOWING. IT'S ABOUT HOW WE
LEARN WITH AND FROM NATIVE
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF. DISCIPLINES
HISTORICALLY THAT ARE FOCUSED
ON THE STUDY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE. MY PATERNAL GRANDMOTHER
WAS ONE OF THE FOUNDERS AND THE
INDIAN TRIBAL EDUCATION
PERSONAL PROGRAM HI TECH- BACK
IN THE LATE SIXTIES AND EARLY
SEVENTIES. HER INTERVENTION
OTHER MOTHERS AND GRANDMOTHERS
THE WERE THE ONES THAT KIND OF
STARTED A LOT OF OUR OTHER-COMMUNITY PROGRAMS ARE HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS ARE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS I ALWAYS THINK IT'S A
PRETTY AMAZING STORY ONE OF
THOSE WOMEN ARE INCLUDED. I'M
HAD ATTENDED BOARDING SCHOOLS
AND FOR THOSE WOMEN TO COME
BACK FROM THAT AND STILL
UNDERSTAND THAT WE NEEDED
HEALTH AND WE NEEDED EDUCATION
AND WE NEEDED A STRONG
COMMUNITY. WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE INDIAN TRAVEL EDUCATIONAL
PERSONAL PROGRAM IN NINETEEN
SERVICES WOMEN WITH MOXIE THEY
COME FROM A GENERATION OF WOMEN
WHO HAVE BEEN HAPPY TO JUST
HOLD THAT STRING FOR SUCH A
LONG TIME. IN PART OF THE
WORKERS TRIBAL PEOPLES HAD WE
BACK IN TAP INTO THAT BECAUSE
IT'S ALWAYS THERE WE COME FROM
A LONG LINE OF THOSE FOLKS WHO
WERE MOVING FORWARD AND I'VE
HAD TO. KEEP THEIR DIGNITY KEEP
THEIR PRIDE. AND ALTHOUGH IT
HURTS. WE'RE STILL DOING NOW.
THAT HAPPENED FOR THE YOUNG
PEOPLE TRAVEL PEOPLE IN
PARTICULAR BUT ALSO FOR NON
AND- TO HEAR THAT TO. THIS NOT
ALL HISTORICAL TRAUMA NUMBER
GOVERNMENT. KNOW WHAT'S IN
STORE FOR TRAUMA WE'RE STILL
HERE AND WE'RE NOT GOING
ANYWHERE. WE'RE STILL LEARNING
WE'RE STILL WONDERING
. ONE
THING I LIKE I LIKE TO GIVE
BEHIND THE SCENES INFORMATION
ABOUT THE MAKING OF THE VIDEO
AND THERE'S A SCENE IN THERE ME
TEACHING MY STUDENTS AND I LOVE
THAT FOOTAGE BECAUSE- THEY
NEVER WRITE NOTES. ARE LIKE
REALLY LOOK LIKE THEY'RE SUPER
INTO WHAT I'M SAYING IN IN THAT
THAT VIDEO WHENEER I'M SAYING
ANYTHING YOU SEE THEM ALL GO
LIKE. REALLY FAST BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING FILMED. SO THE
WHOLE. THE WHOLE TIME THEY WERE
BEING FILMED. EVERY TIME I'D
SAY SOMETHING THEY GO ALL IN
THAT ALL RIGHT AND THEY LOOK
REALLY REALLY INTO IT SO I WAS
LIKE ANY VIEWS THAT IN MY FILE.
I THINK ONE REASON WHY I MADE
THIS VIDEO IS BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO GIVE PEOPLE A WAY TO BE
INTRODUCED TO CALIFORNIA AND IN
HISTORY- BUT WE ALSO WANTED TO
REMIND THEM THAT- THE
CALIFORNIAN IN HISTORY THAT WE
TELL IS NOT JUST ABOUT.
GENOCIDE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
SORT OF THE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION IT'S KIND OF ABOUT
THEWAYS IN WHICH WE ARE.
THRIVING TODAY AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHO WE ARE AS
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE TODAY.
AND WHEN WE SHOWED THE VIDEO IN
PUBLIC SPACES WHAT WE LIKE TO
DO IS TO GUIDE PEOPLE PASSED.
THE MOMENT. THE FIRST BEING
INTRODUCED TO THE HORROR
EPICNESS OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
THE STATE OF. AN IN SOME OF.
THE MORE HORRIFIC ACTS OF
VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENED AGAINST
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE TO
FOUND WHAT BECAME THE STATE.
AND THEY WILL SERVE NOT MOVE
PAST THAT PART. AND STAY. AND
STAY THERE AND THEN NOT BE ABLE
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY STILL HERE
STILL DOING MANY THINGS IS
STILL VERY INVOLVED- IN OUR
LAND MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. AND
IN BUILDING THE FUTURE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US WHEN WE
SHOW THE VIDEO TO ALWAYS POINT
THAT. AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE THINK ABOUT HOW THE
VIDEO ENDED WITH THE MESSAGE
OF. WHO WE ARE TODAY AND NOT
SORT OF JUST ENDED IN THIS
DISCUSSION OF CALIFORNIA
HISTORY IS REALLY TRAGIC
MOMENT. OF AN ATTEMPTED
GENOCIDE OF AN ENTIRE PEOPLE.
I'M I WANT. MY TO THE PO TODAY
WITH. THE TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
FISH KILL IN THE TRINITY IN
KLAMATH RIVERS. THE REASON WHY
IS THAT I REMEMBER VERY CLEARLY
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO
STANDING UP THE HILL AND
LOOKING OUT OVER THE TRINITY IN
KLAMATH RIVERS. I WITH MY
GRANDFATHER. MY GRANDFATHER'S
NAME WAS MILTON WEALTHY. HE WAS
A FORESTER I'M IN A TREE FALLER
AND PROBABLY THE TOUGHEST GUY
THAT I KNEW. IN MY LIFE HE'S A
TELL ME A STORY ABOUT HOW ONE
TIME A TREE STARTED FALLING
WHILE HE WAS STILL ON THE TOP
F IT. AND HE RAN DOWN THE
ENTIRE TREE SO THAT NOTHING
WOULD HAPPEN TO HIM AND THEN
JUMPED OFF OF IT. AND JUST
BROKE HIS WRIST. HE WAS
SUPERMAN. ME AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO BECAUSE OF THE
HIGHER ORDER. NUMBER TRIPS TO
THE LOW WATER FLOWS THAT
HAPPENED. WITH THE DAM WE
EXPERIENCE THE FISH CAN.
OBSERVE HOUSES OF FISH. ARE
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DEAD FISH SITTING ON THE
SHORES OF OUR RIVER. AND WE
WALKING OUT AND BROWN. HAD WHAT.
YOU ARE. MY GRANDFATHER WHO HAD
NEVER MY LOVE SCENE CRIED HIS
VOICE CRACKED HE SHED TEARS AND
HE SAID WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR
OUR FUTURE WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
FOR OUR WORLD. IT BECOMES
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
HISTORY OF GENOCIDE IN THE
STATE IS WHAT BUILT THE
POLICIES THAT CONTINUE THINGS
LIKE THE SEIZURE OF OUR WATER
THE BUILDING OF DAMS THE WAYS
IN WHICH WE POURED AND THEY
POURED MERCURY INTO THE WATER
THAT WE STILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH
WE ARE STILL DEALING WITH.
PERCUSSIONS OF WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE SYSTEM AND THE GOLD
RUSH AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD WHEN I
TEACH CALIFORNIA HISTORY. AND
I'M INVITED TO SORT OF TRAIN A
LOT OF PEOPLE ON HISTORY. I TRY
TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND AND
SHOW THAT HISTORY IS STILL
INFORMING WHAT'S HAPPENING
TODAY. AND TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
KEEP GOING ON AND NOT TO THINK
THIS IS THE ONLY INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITY. PEOPLE HAVE WRITTEN
MANY. THIS I WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO READ. BUT THE TWO THAT I
ALWAYS ELL PEOPLE TO START
WITH OUR GENOCIDE IN NORTH WEST
CALIFORNIA. BY JACK NORTON AND
BAD INDIANS BY DEBORAH MARANDA.
I THINK I'S IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE MISSION MYTHOLOGY
THAT'S FOR REDDING CALIFORNIA
THROUGH OUR MISSION PROJECT AND
I MISSION CURRICULUM TEACHES
PEOPLE THAT THE MISSION SYSTEM
WAS BE NINE. BUT IT IS NOT THE
CASE IN FACT SEXUAL ASSAULT OF
A WOMAN WITH ONE OF THE FIRST
ACTS RECORDED BY MISSIONARIES
AS A RESULT OF THE SYSTEM. THIS
YEAR ALSO MARKS THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF JACK NORTON
GENOCIDE IN NORTH WEST
CALIFORNIA NORTON IS A WHO BUT
CHEROKEE SCHOLAR AND WHAT HE
VIEWED WITH THAT WHAT HAPPENED
IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE GENOCIDE
HE USE SETTLER ARCHIVES TO
PROVE THAT. HE TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THE MOST HORRIFIC
THINGS THAT HAPPENED TO OUR
PEOPLE TO MY PEOPLE AND FAMILY
THINGS LIKE MASSACRES THE
INDISCRIMINATE KILLING OF WOMEN
AND CHILDREN AND THE CREATION
OF LAWS THAT ALLOW THEM TO A
SLAVE. CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE
IN THE CALIFORNIA ENTERED THE
STATE THE MAN KNOWS THE STATE.
LOOK AT THE WAY RECORDS
HUMBOLDT COUNTY WHAT YOU DOUBT.
THAT MOST PEOPLE IN SLAVE UNDER
THESE LAWS AND CAL. WERE
ACTUALLY CHILDREN. AGES SEVEN
TO TWELVE AND MOST OF THOSE
WERE YOUNG GIRLS. SO REALLY
THEY HAD CREATED A SYSTEM OF
SEX SLAVERY IN WHICH THEY WERE
TRADING AT YOUNG WOMEN AMONGST
EACH OTHER. THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE TODAY WE
STILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
REPLICATIONS OF THIS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE FACT. THAT WE ARE
THE MOST LIKELY GROUP OF PEOPLE
TO BE RATE IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA WE ARE THE MOST
LIKELY TO GO MISSING. AND
MURDERED WE ARE THE MOST LIKELY
TO BE TRAPPED IN THE THAT'S
THAT'S THAT DON'T ESCAPE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
THE LASTING THIS IS THE LAST
THING. HAPPENED THREE GENOCIDE.
I WE ARE FORCED TO PROTECT OUR
YOUNG GIRLS TO. THEM WAY ONCE
AGAIN TO PROTECT THEM. NOT JUST
THROUGH LEGISLATION BUT THROUGH
THE WAY THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
US AND KNOW THAT WE ARE PEOPLE.
WE CONTINUE TO ALSO HAVE TO
FIGHTFOR OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. THE
GOLD RUSH WAS DESTRUCTIVE TO
THE ENVIRONMENT LANDS RECEIVED
AS A RESULT OF THE GOLD RUSH
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THIS STATE. THAT
STILL TRACE THEIR RIGHTS TO
LAND AND OWNERSHIP OF LAND AND
WATER BACK TO THE GOLD RUSH.
LOOK AT THE WAY. THEY WERE. I'M
LEAD. TIME IT WAS AS A DIRECT
RESULT OF KILLING AND MASSACRES
OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE.
AFTER MASSACRE SETTLERS WOULD
ENTER THE REGION THEY WOULD
MAKE UP DOCUMENTS AND THEY
WOULD SAY THAT THEY NOW OWNED
THAT LAND AND ONLY TO THOSE
RESOURCES. TRACING BACK ANY
TYPE OF OWNERSHIP TO THE
CALIFORNIA GOLD RUSH ERASES THE
VIOLENCE THAT IT TOOK TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. IF WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT TWO THREE HEALING IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN'T SPEND THE
NEXT FEW YEARS JUST TESTIFYING
TO OUR HISTORIES. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF THE STATE GOVERNMENT
WE NEED TO BE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP CONCRETE
ACTIONS AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT WHILE WE HAVE THE EAR OF
OUR NEW GOVERNOR WE HAVE TO
REMIND HIM THAT OUR WORK IS ON
GOING. THAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR A LONG TIME AND THAT
WE SHOULD BE INTO BECAUSE WE
ARE STILL HERE. AS LEADERS YOU
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO LEARN
MORE ALSO BE ACCOUNTABLE TO
INDIAN PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND NOT ONLY WHAT
ABOUT OUR HISTORY BUT OUR
ONGOING ISSUES WITH WATER. SAM
AND REMOVAL OUR YOUTH ARE WOMEN
AND FUTURES NATIVE PEOPLE HAVE
THE HIGHEST RATE OF SUICIDE IN
THE COUNTRY. WE ARE LESS THAN
2% OF THE POPULATION OUR YOUTH
ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO COMMIT.
I HAD A- GROUP. THE NATURE.
WOMEN ARE ONES WHO ARE FORCED
TO DO. WITH THE POLICIES THAT
ARE PASSED THAT DON'T PROTECT
US. THERE ARE PARTS OF THE YEAR
WHEN OUR WATER IS TOXIC TO US
BECAUSE OF THE SEIZURE OF WATER
TO BUILD RESERVOIRS FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
AGRICULTURE. WE LIVE THIS EVERY
DAY. I WAS INVITED TO HELP YOU
ALL OVER VIEW CALIFORNIAN IN
HISTORY. BUT I ASK YOU TO
PLEASE BE MINDFUL THAT
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN REMINDED THAT WE
ARE STILL HERE. AND WE MUST.
BUILD OUR FUTURES WITH OUR
PAST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION.
JUDY QUESTIONS- COMMENTS OR
ANYTHING FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
SEVERAL WOMEN CARILLO. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THAT A WONDERFUL
PRESENTATION AND VIDEO- A PART
OF THE CONVERSATION THAT WE'VE
DISCUSSED BEFORE AND I LOVE
YOUR THOUGHTS IS HOW DO WE TALK
ABOUT THE INCLUSION OR THE
HISTORY OF. CALIFORNIA BEING
THREE TIMES COLONIZED SO X. AGO
I'M SORRY SPAIN MEXICO UNITED
STATES AND HOW DO WE WILL WE'RE
TRYING TO TALK WITH SOME OF MY
MEDINA ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES.
HOW DO WE INCORPORATE- HELP
SUGGEST THAT WE AS LEGISLATORS
TACKLE THAT THAT SUBJECT. I'D I
THINK ONE THING THAT I FIND
REALLY IMPORTANT ABOUT
CALIFORNIA IS TO CONSIDER IT
AS- LIKE AN AMALGAM OF HISTORY
SO ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT IT HISTORY ACTUALLY COMES
TO. TO PLAY A LOT IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
MISSION SYSTEM THAT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH LIKE THE MEXICAN
RANCHERAS SYSTEM AND THEN ALSO
THE GOLD RUSH OTHER THINGS
CONVERGE TOGETHER IN CALIFORNIA
AND THEY ALSO HAPPEN IN
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE WORLD.
AND THEY AFFECT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE SO WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING BUT SAY A THE MISSION
SYSTEM I'VE FINING REALLY
INTERESTING MOMENTS OF THINKING
ABOUT WHO ARE THE ACTUAL PEOPLE
THAT ARE INVOLVED. IN THE
SPANISH SIDE OF IT IF YOU LOOK
AT THE SPANISH SOLDIERS WE HAVE
AN ASSUMPTION OF WHO THEY MIGHT
BE THEY TEND TO ACTUALLY BE. A
LOT OF THEM ARE- LIKE PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN SLAVE TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE FORCED INTO THIS SOLDIER
SYSTEM BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY
WAY TO GET TO MOVE UP THE CASTE
SYSTEM. THERE'S A LOT REALLY
INTERESTING MOMENTS TO THINK
ABOUT THE INTERSECTION ALLERGY
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY- AND I
ACTUALLY THINK LEARNING ABOUT
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HISTORY.
LENDS ITSELF REALLY WELL TO
ETHNIC STUDIES AS A CURRICULUM
BECAUSE OF HOW INVOLVED- SO
MANY DIFFERENT PEOPLE WERE IN
THE BUILDING AS HAS. I THINK IT
CAN IN MY MIND WE HAVE TO
CENTER CALIFORNIA INDIANS FIRST
BECAUSE WE ARE YOU OFTEN THEM.
THE MOST ARE BASED SO THE ONES
AT. I THINK ARE JUST IN THE
PAST. AND WE NEED TO BILL ANY
LIMIT THE FOR ALSO AN ACTIVE
PART WHAT'S GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU OF FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. KIND OF
FOLLOWING UP ON AN MISCARRY OF.
I GREW UP- HI THIS NATIVE
AMERICAN WORD MEANING NEST NOT
SURE WHAT LANGUAGE VENTURA
COUNTY. I REMEMBER AS A YOUNG
MAN- MAKING MOCCASINS AND BEAT
IT SO IN THE BEADS. AS A BOY
SCOUT IN I GREW UP IN CATHOLIC
SCHOOL BUILDING THE MISSIONS
BUT I GROWING UP. IN OJAI
THOUGHT THAT I HAD TO TRAVEL TO
ARIZONA. IF I HAD INTEREST IN
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE. I WENT
TO COLLEGE AND I GOT A MASTERS
IN HISTORY OF WHICH I'M VERY
PROUD OF. IT OF THE GETTING A
MASTERS IN HISTORY AT UC
RIVERSIDE A PLACE THAT THAT
HAS- EXCELLENT PROGRAM AT
NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORY BUT I
GO BACK TO HOW I GREW UP AND
NOT EVEN KNOWING THE EXISTENCE
LEARN ABOUT THE EXISTENCE. OF
NATIVE AMERICANS IN. ELEVEN
MILES WERE PROBABLY IN THE SAME
PLACE WHERE I GREW UP- YOU KNOW
IT WAS ONLY AFTER GETTING
ELECTED TO THE LEGISLATURE I
REALLY DO THINK THAT I LEARNED
THE SHOE MUCH PEOPLE- INVENTOR
AND THEIR HISTORY IN THE
ISLANDS OFF THE COAST OF
VENTURA. AND HAVE BEEN VERY
WELL IMPRESSED WITH CHANNEL
ISLANDS EFFORTS TO INCORPORATE
LIKE YOU HAVE IN THE VIDEO
SCIENCE A NATIVE AMERICAN
EXISTENCE AND PRESENCE IN THE
SCIENCE RESEARCH THAT THEY
CONDUCT. IN THE CHANNEL ISLANDS.
BUT I AM STILL- YOU KNOW IT IS
SO UNFORTUNATE I BELIEVE AS AN
EDUCATOR. AS A LEGISLATOR THAT
THE TWELVE MINUTES OF VIDEO
THAT YOU SHOWED HERE. IN MY
LIFETIME WAS NEVER EVER. TALK
TO ME SO THAT WHEN I LEARNED
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA MISSIONS.
IT WAS ALMOST TO THE EXCLUSION
OF THE NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE I
RECOGNIZED I THINK A PICTURE OF
THE BOARDING SCHOOL IT LOOK
LIKE SHERMAN. INDIAN BOARDING
SCHOOL THAT IS IN RIVERSIDE IN
THE DISTRICT THAT I NOW
REPRESENT AND I THINK THAT
THERE WAS A PICTURE OF THEIR OF
THE OF THE- OF THE BOARDING
SCHOOL IN RIVERSIDE SO I VERY
MUCH HOPE THAT IT IN OUR EFFORT
TO CREATE A CURRICULA- OF
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL THAT. THIS HISTORY
NATIVE AMERICAN HISTORY I WILL
BE YOU KNOW A. VERY MUCH
CENTERED AS YOU SAID IN THAT
CALIFORNIA HISTORY BECAUSE IT
IS A CENTRAL PART OF THE
HISTORY BUT UNFORTUNATELY IN MY
LIFETIME WHEN THAT WAS NEVER
EVEN MENTIONED. THANK YOU A
SEVERE MEDINA ASSEMBLY WOMAN-
MANAT MONIQUE LIMON HAS JOINED
US THANK YOU AND I REGRET THAT
HAD TO GET HERE LATE BUT AS
TIMING WOULD HAVE IT'S A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST AND I
WERE PRESENTING AND EDUCATION
COMMITTEE ON A WAY TO FIND
FUNDING TO CREATE AND NATIVE
AMERICAN. CURRICULUM FOR K.
TWELVE- AND IT WAS A BILL THAT
PASSED A COUPLE YEARS AGO BUT
THE FUNDING WASN'T THERE AND
SO- A THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERTS HAS TALKED A BIT ABOUT.
HOW YOU RECTIFY HISTORY AND
IT'S NOT JUST TO SHOW INTENT
BUT TO ALSO PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO MAKE SOME OF THIS REALITY- I
APPRECIATE YOUR HEARING- WHAT
MORE WE CAN DO AND HOW
DIFFERENTLY WE CAN THINK ABOUT
PRESENTING AN UNTOLD HISTORY
UNTOLD STORY THAT IS VERY MUCH
PRESENT- IN VERY MUCH REAL- IT
TO THE FIRST PEOPLE'S HERE. SO
I THINK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
I REGRET THAT I HAD IN THIS
VIDEO THAT EVERYONE'S
REFERENCE- BUT BUT I DO THINK
YOU OF FOR ENHANCING ADVANCING
THIS CONVERSATION. AND I DID
WANT TO POINT OUT ONE THING
THAT I LEARNED A LOT FROM DOING
THESE KINDS OF PRESENTATIONS IS
HOW MUCH THE FOURTH GRADE
MISSION PROJECT IN A IMPACTS ON
HOW PEOPLE KNOW INDIAN PEOPLE
AND SO. WHEN PEOPLE SAY OH IT'S
JUST IN THE FOURTH GRADERS
ALONG. WITH MY STUDENTS COME IN
THAT'S WHAT THEY INTERNALIZED
WAS THEIR FOURTH GRADE MISSION
PROJECT AND EVEN IF IN HIGH
SCHOOL THEY LEARNED AFTER THAT
SOME OTHER THINGS ABOUT THE
MISSIONS. THEY STILL REALLY
TALK ABOUT FOR THE FOURTH GRADE
IS VERY INFLUENTIAL ON THEM AS
STUDENTS. AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
WORRY THAT YOU CAN'T TEACH THE
REAL MISSION HISTORY IN THE
FOURTH GRADE. BUT MY DAUGHTER-
WHEN SHE HAD TO DO HER FOURTH
GRADE MISSION PROJECT- DECIDED
TO DO THE SAN DIEGO MISSION.
AND WHAT SHE WAS GOING TO DO IS
BUILD IT AND THEN SET IT ON
FIRE AND THEN TURN IN THE ASHES
OF THAT PROJECT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THE COOLEY I HAD DONE WHEN
THEY REVOLTED THEY HAD SET THE
MISSION ON FIRE. AND WE BOTH
SAID IT WOULD BE HISTORICALLY
ACCURATE- AND INSTEAD SHE BUILT
THE MISSION AND PUT FLAMES UP
THE SIDE AND SHE WROTE HER
REPORT ABOUT THE COOLEY AYE
REVOLTS AND RESISTANCE TO THE
MISSION SYSTEM. ANSWERING ALL
OF THE QUESTIONS OF THE FOURTH
GRADE CURRICULUM BUT IN A WAY
THAT CENTERED INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES AND IT WAS VERY
POWERFUL THE WATCHER DO THAT
AND TO ALSO THEN SEE WHAT SHE
SAID TO STUDENTS. SO I KNOW
THAT FOURTH GRADERS CAN HANDLE
IT AND I KNOW THAT WE CAN'T
JUST TAKE OUT. THIS IDEA OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THESE
COMPLEX CONVERSATIONS AND WHEN
I ASKED HER LIKE DID IT MAKE
YOU FOR SATURDAY THAT MAKE YOU
THINK SOMETHING BAD AND SHE
SAID NO. IT MADE ME REALIZE
THAT CALIFORNIA INDIANS ARE
REALLY STRONG PEOPLE. AND I
WANT HER TO LEARN THAT FROM OUR
STATE CURRICULUM I WANT ALL
STUDENTS TO LEARN THAT. AND SHE
WAS LIKE IT MADE ME REALIZE
THAT WE WERE ALWAYS FIGHTING.
AND THAT WE KNEW WE WERE GOING
TO. OR SO SHE INTERNALIZES THAT
OF THE MESSAGE OF WE WERE ALL
DYING TO. WE WERE VERY VERY
STRONG PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK WE SHOULD DO WITH OUR
CURRICULUM IS EMPOWER ARE USED
TO THINK ABOUT NATIVE PEOPLE
THAT WAY. EXCELLENT THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO GIVE A- SPECIAL
RECOGNITION TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEMOND FOR AUTHORING WAS IT
LAST YEAR THE BILL THAT
ACTUALLY. THAT ACTUALLY
TACKLED- THE MISSION PROJECT IN
THE SUGAR CUBE PROJECT WHICH I
ALSO DID- IN. THIRD OR FOURTH
GRADE- REPRESENTATION MATTERS.
AND REPRESENTATION THAT IS
SENSITIVE TO THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE REPRESENT. MATTERS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING HERE
TODAY. THANK YOU AGAIN- DR
WRESTLING BALDING FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE WITH US TODAY. THANK
YOU. I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW. TO ALSO
INTRODUCE OUR OUR COLLEAGUE WHO
HAS JOINED US HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SAY A FEW WORDS. TO QUESTION
THE ONLY DRIVER OKAY. THE
DOLPHINS AND- THANK YOU WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
ARE CHAIR ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST
HAD TO STEP OUT TO PRESENT
ANOTHER COMMITTEE OUR NEXT
SPEAKER IS DOCTOR SALLY
RODRIGUEZ WHO IS A MEMBER OF
THE SENT THAT YOU SEVEN BAND OF
THE PIE NATION AND SERVES AS A
TEACHER AN ADVISER IN THE SAN.
DIEGO AND NATIVE. ME CALL ME
THESE AT HE WILL ADDRESS THE
PERSPECTIVE OF FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES WELCOME. TO
THE HEARING. HOW WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A OKAY LET ME INTRODUCE
OUR ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS THAT
ARE JOINING EFFORT WAS UNAWARE
SORRY AND SO IN ADDITION- TO
DOCTOR RODRIGUEZ WE ALSO HAVE
MISS MERRY LOPEZ KEY FOR A
MEMBER OF THE SAN LEASE RAY BAN
OF MISSION INDIANS AND
COMMISSIONER AND SECRETARY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION. SHE WILL
SPEAK ON THE PERSPECTIVE OF NON
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES. IN
ADDITION TO IN ADDITION A WILL
ALSO HEAR FROM MISTER RAYMOND
HITCHCOCK OF THE ME WALK IN NY
SEN MASON ON ME FINANCE THAT MY
APOLOGIES MSON ON DISSENT HE
CURRENTLY SERVES AS THE TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN AND CEO OF THE WILTON
RANCHERIA THE ONLY NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE AND- CAPPY.
MISTER COCKE WILL DISCUSS THE
IT ACCESS THE FEDERAL TERMINATE
POLICY OF CALIFORNIA TRIBES
WELCOME THANK YOU. IN. OKAY
BENYAMIN SOME STAMINA TO HANNAH
MICHAEL BY WITH ONE NINE. BILL
HERE LOCALLY NO WAY WE'LL PAY
YOU YEAH BUT WHAT WHAT DIE
NIPPLE WATCH- TOMORROW YOU KNOW
QUICK BY. DOUBLE MAKE ENOUGH
MONEY. MY NO WAY NEW ERA CAN BE.
A JUDGE LIFTED NEAR HILLA COREY.
BOOK NOT JUST NO WAY COULD NOT
TELL YOU HON GOING UP WHAT HAN.
COULD NOT BEAR HUNT. MULTI THIS
AT ALL OF THE NUMBERS DON'T
RODRIGUEZ YOU'LL SOLELY BY
COMING AT THE ZEBRA CENTERS OF
IN. YOUR WITH IT DOES ONLY
PHYLLIS'S BUT CAN ALSO TO
STACKING. THE BOTTOM OF THE
RIVER STUCK IN THE CELLS WHEN
HE WAS IN SAN DIEGO. WELL TO
PUT THIS ON WATER LEVEL AND BY
HOW CALIFORNIA MAKE WAS PRETTY
GOOD BUT AS BUNION. SO THEIR
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICABLE TO THE
COLLEGE. WE ARE AN OPERATIONAL
TRIBAL COLLEGE LOCATED IN SAN
DIEGO. WHICH OFFERS AN
ACCREDITED ASSOCIATES PROGRAM
AND CALL ME I STUDIES. SO AGAIN
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IT IS AN
HONOR FOR ME TO SPEAK. TO ALL
OF ALL OF YOU HERE. SO WHAT I
WANTED TO. TALK ABOUT YOU ASKED
ME TO TALK ABOUT FEDERAL
RECOGNITION FOR FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES. YOU KNOW
THERE'S- URBAN LEGEND. THAT
NATIVE AMERICANS GET THIS CHECK
FROM THE. FROM THE GOVERNMENT
GET THAT INDIAN MY. HAVE YOU
SEEN A BECAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN
IT I HAVEN'T SEEN IT SO WHAT
WE'LL BE TALKING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT AND SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS HAVE BEEN GOING ON.
FIRST OF ALL YOU'RE A- CULTURE
RISEN THANK YOU DOCTOR ISN'T
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. AND I HAVE A TEN
YEAR OLD SON WHO'S IN FOURTH
GRADE. AND I'M ALSO GONNA DO
THE SAN DIEGO MISSION. AND THE
BURNING. AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT WENT WITH THAT. BECAUSE
OUR PEOPLE. ARE NOT VICTIMS.
OUR PEOPLE HAVE RESISTED
CONTINUE TO RESIST AND WE LIVE
TODAY. SO. TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WE AS NATIVE PEOPLE
HAVE HAD TO INDOOR THREE WAVES
OF ENCROACHMENT. FIRST SUSPEND
THEIR HERE FOR ABOUT FIFTY
YEARS FOR FURTHER CAME OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO THEY DID A-
THEY DO A PAGEANT IN SAN DIEGO
EVERY SEPTEMBER CABRILLO COMING
IN- THESE THAT PEOPLE DRESSED
UP AS COOLEY AYE GENUINE
SELECTING IN FRONT OF THEM THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN WILL HAPPEN
ACTUALLY WAS A LOT OF THURMOND
GOT SHOT BY COMMUNITIES. WHO
ENCROACHING INTO OUR TERRITORY.
AFTER THAT. THEY CAME BACK
AGAIN AND SEVENTEEN SIXTY NINE
THE MISSION WAS CREATED WAS
BURNED DOWN NOVEMBER FIFTH
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE. THE A
DURING THE MEXICAN REVOLUTION
MEXICO WAS FINALLY- GAINED
INDEPENDENCE THEY WERE GONNA
SECULARIZED EMISSION BUT THEY
MAKE THESE ESTANCIAS TO COMBAT
PEOPLE CONTINUED ATTACKS. SAN
DIEGO MISSPELLED THREE TIMES TO
CALL ME I TAX LAST TIME IT WAS
REPELLED BY A BRITISH SCHOOL IN
THE BAY. WELL THEN THE MEXICAN
AMERICAN WAR CAME. UP TO ME AS
TO ACTIVELY FIGHTING AGAINST
MAX AND AMERICANS CAME- JOE
KERN GOT. HE WAS STUCK IN SAN
DIEGO WHO'S GOMEZ I CAME TO HIS
AID THEY SAID THAT THEY WOULD.
HELP THE NATIVE PEOPLE IF THEY
WERE ABLE TO WIN THE WAR. WHEN
THAT HAPPENED. GOVERNOR THE
FIRST GOVERNOR HERE THE
CALIFORNIA HE WAS THE ONE THAT
STARTED THE GENOCIDE UNAIDED
NATIVE PEOPLE THAT WAS FOLLOWED
BY GOVERNMENT DO. WHAT HAPPENED
THEN WAS AN M. PRIOR TO THE
GOLD RUSH THE NATIVE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA OF. THE POPULATION
WAS 80% OF THE STATE. AND
SOMETHING ABOUT CALIFORNIA IS
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL DIVERSITY THAN ANY
OTHER PLACE IN THE WORLD ASIDE
FROM PAPUA NEW GUINEA. THAT
SPEAKS. TO THE DIVERSITY HERE
IN THE STATE AND YOU KNOW OF
EVERYTHING THAT WENT WITH IT. A
FEW YEARS AFTER GOLD RUSH. 80%
OF THE PEOPLE WERE GONE. THEY
HAD BEEN KILLED WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT GENOCIDE IT WAS I MEAN AN
INCREDIBLE PROPORTIONS.
SCHWARZKOPF CAME SO HE WAS
HIRED BY BY STATE TO DEVELOP
EIGHTEEN TREES TO MAKE EIGHTEEN
TREATIES. THE TREATY OF SET I
BELIEVE- MISTER RAMOS SURE WERE
YOU UNDER THE TREATY OF
TEMECULA ARE YOU YOUR UNDER
DIFFERENT TREATY. WAS A
DIFFERENT ONE THAN THE TREE OF
TEMECULA CAME. OKAY AND THEN
THE TREATY OF SAN ISABLLE CAME
IT WAS- IT WAS SIGNED JANUARY
SEVENTH 1-540-184-0218 FIFTY
TWO. AND A PROMISES A
RESERVATION FROM THE MEXICAN
BORDER BUT A VERY CLOSE TO
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. THIS WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A RESERVATION
AND THE RESERVATIONS WERE
CREATED IN ORDER TO GIVE THE
NATIVE PEOPLE. AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO I MEAN TO LIVE WE HAD THE
RESOURCES THE ENVIRONMENTAL
RESOURCE OF WHAT WE COULD
SUPPORT OURSELVES. WHAT IS
EIGHTEEN TREATIES WERE NOT
RATIFIED. HUGE LANGRES TOOK
PLACE IN YOU GOTTA REMEMBER
THIS WAS ON THE EVE OF THE
CIVIL WAR. SO LET OF PEOPLE
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA HAD
CONFEDERATE LEANINGS. SO WHAT
WAS GOING ON WAS THEY WERE
BASICALLY PETITIONING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT IF YOU
SEND US. YOUR TREATED FOR GOING
TO SIDE WITH THE CONFEDERACY.
SO THOSE TREATED TO NEVER
RATIFIED. SO WHAT HAPPENED WAS
AND OUR PEOPLE DID NOT ABROGATE
ON ANY PROVISIONS OF THOSE
TREES WE NEVER BROKEN
PROVISIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT HUGE LAND GRABS TOOK
PLACE. SO WHAT SAVED US WELL
I'M I'M NOT EVEN AS A SAVED AS
WHAT HAPPENED THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE RESERVATIONS CAME BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER. THAT CAME FROM
ULYSSES S. GRANT. AND. SEN THE
RESERVATIONS THAT WERE CREATED
AN IF ANY OF YOU ARE AWARE OF
SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO AS MORE
RESERVATIONS IN ANY OTHER
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY WE HAVE
A- RESERVATIONS. WELL SAID THE
SMALLEST RESERVE A- BUT THESE
DIVISIONS THAT WERE CREATED
WERE NOT CREATED FOR US TO BE
SELF SUFFICIENT. THERE CREATED
BASICALLY TO TELL US TO
QUESTION THE PEOPLE. AND I'M
SURE THE RESERVATIONS UPPER
WERE EVEN SMALLER. SO WITH THAT
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE HERO
WITH THE PEOPLE WELL AS- YOU
KNOW YOU LIVE IN A CERTAIN AREA.
AND LARGE ENOUGH POPULATION
SMALL ENOUGH AREA YOU'RE GONNA
DEPLETE THE RESOURCES OF THAT
AREA SO WHAT IS HAPPENING DâN.
THE BUREAU OF INDIAN AFFAIRS TO
THE ANY COMMISSIONS WERE
SUPPOSED TO BRING IN SUPPLIES.
MANY OF THOSE SUPPLIES WENT TO
THE GOLD RUSH. TO SUPPLY PEOPLE
TO SUPPLY PEOPLE OUT THERE
PEOPLE WERE STARVING ON THE
RESERVATION PEOPLE HAD TO GO
AND- ENGAGING CATTLE RUSTLING
OR DOING WHATEVER THEY COULD IN
ORDER TO FEED THE FAMILIES THIS
IS HOW BAD IT GOT. AND ALSO
SOME DATA AB ONE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES EIGHTEEN EIGHTY. THIS
WAS THE START OF THE BOARDING
SCHOOL ERA COLONEL PRESS. HE'S
THE ONE THAT MADE THE FAMOUS
SAYING KILL THE INDIAN AND SAVE
THE MAN THEY WERE TAKING
CHILDREN AWAY FROM THE
COMMUNITIES AND THIS WAS
HAPPENING OF AS LATE AS THE
NINETEEN FORTIES NINETEEN
FIFTIES. I KNOW IT TOOK AWAY
AND THEY WILL CUT THEIR HAIR.
AND. WHEN I TALK ABOUT CUTTING
THE HAIR IT MEANS MORE THAN
THAT. IF YOU LOOK AT THIS. THIS
IS PART OF WHO WE ARE IN OUR
CREATION STORIES WE HAVE THE
SAME CREATION STORIES. IT TALKS
ABOUT THE WILDCAT HAD A LONG
TAIL BUT WHEN THE CREATOR DIED
BECAUSE STILL IN MOURNING SO WE
DO THAT SO WHEN YOU CUT
SOMEBODY'S HERE YOU. YOU PUT
SOMEBODY IN MORNING. YOU PUT
SOMEBODY A AND A SENSE OF LAWS.
pWHAT IT WAS ILLEGAL FOR US TO
PRACTICE OUR RELIGION. AND IT
WAS ILLEGAL TO PRACTICE OUR I'M
TO SPEAK OUR LANGUAGE. IT
WASN'T UNTIL THE FREEDOM OF
AMERICAN INDIAN RELIGION ACT
WAS PASSED IN AUGUST ELEVENTH
OF NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. THAT
WE HAD THE SAME PROTECTION AS
ANYBODY ELSE. AS EVERYBODY ELSE
IN THIS COUNTRY. AND WAS UNTIL
THE NINETEEN NINETIES THERE ARE
LANGUAGES WERE PROTECTED. SO
THESE ARE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAD. NO OTHER
RESERVATIONS IS A SAID WE KNOW
WE DO OF. IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
BE ABLE TO SUSTAIN ON THAT
RESERVATION THE LANDS THAT WERE
PUT. REMEMBER OUR PEOPLES WERE
FROM THE COAST ALL THE WAY TO
THE DESERT. SO THE BEST LANDS
THE NATIVE PEOPLE REJECTED WERE
FORCIBLY REMOVED PUSHED ON TO
THESE LANDS HAD NOBODY WANTED.
THESE LANDS AT WERE VERY
DIFFICULT TO SUSTAIN. SO AS
THIS STARTED HAPPENING. THE
GOVERNMENT CAME IN AND THEY
WERE TAKING CHILDREN AWAY FOR
THE BOARDING SCHOOLS THEY WERE
COMING BACK MANY OF THEM DID
WHAT I CALL COACH WHICH THEY
WOULD SPEAK IN THE LANGUAGE AND
THEN WHEN THE WHEN AND IT WOULD
BE PUNISHED FOR SPEAKING THEIR
LANGUAGE THEY WERE TALKING
ENGLISH TO THEM. BUT WHAT THEY
IT HAD A DELAYED AFFECT WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN WAS WHEN THEY WENT
HOME THEY WOULD TELL THEIR
SIBLINGS YOU'RE GONNA BE GOING
TO BOARDING SCHOOL NEXT DON'T
TALK OUR LANGUAGE THEY'RE GOING
TO HURT YOU JUST TALK IN
ENGLISH SO THESE ARE SOME OF
THE PROBLEMS THAT. THAT WERE
TAKING PLACE. NOW REMEMBER I
TOLD YOU- THE FREEDOM OF
AMERICAN INTO RELIGION ACT WAS.
WAS WAS PASSED IN AUGUST
ELEVENTH NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS
THIS. PROTECTION OF LANGUAGE
CULTURE AND RELIGION. MEANS
NOTHING IF YOU HAVE NO MORE
LANGUAGE CULTURE RELIGION LEFT
TO PROTECT. THEY WERE STILL I
MEAN IT WAS IT YOU KNOW THEY
WERE STILL IN OF PIECES OF IT
GOING. NO WE TALKED ABOUT YOUR
TEACHER. AND YOU KNOW HOW HE
KEPT IT GOING. SO BACK TO THE
RESERVATIONS THE RESERVATION TO
A HARD PLACE TO LIVE ON. WAS
VERY DIFFICULT AND NO RUNNING
WATER NO ELECTRICITY ON THE
SENATE BY RESERVATION I
REMEMBER- A JIM WAS MADE. AND
THAT WAS THE PLACE WHERE PEOPLE
WOULD COME AND TAKE SHOWERS
TRIBAL MEMBERS ARE SOMETIMES IT
WILL COME TO COOK. IT WAS A
HARD PLACE TO LIVE. AND MY
UNCLE HE TOLD ME WHEN HE WENT
TO BOARDING SCHOOL. HE SAID
THAT HE WAS TAKEN ALL THE WAY
TO- THEY HAD SEEN BOND OFFICE.
A IN IN BANNING AND THEN THEY
ALSO HAD SAN FRANCISCO IN
ARIZONA. AND THEY WOULD TAKE-
NATIVE CHILDREN TO THE
DIFFERENT DIVISIONS MANY OF
THEM ESCAPED. SO THESE ARE SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT THAT WE
HAD THERE. ALSO IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NATIVE COMMUNITIES
ON THE RESERVATION. DEVELOPING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT THE POPULATION. WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY WITHOUT RUNNING
WATER IT CAN BE DIFFICULT AND
PEOPLE TEND TO CONGREGATE WHERE
THEY ARE ABLE TO GET THE
SERVICES ALSO ANOTHER THING
THAT'S HAPPENING THAT YOU ALL
KNOW OF IS WE ARE GOING INTO A
DROUGHT OR WELL IT'S ON A
RESERVATIONS ARE SEARCHING
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE'RE ON A
FAULT LINE THAT WATER IS GOING
INTO THE- INTO LAKE HENSHAW. AS
GOING INTO THE VISTA WATER
DISTRICT SO IT'S SERVING
MEMBERS IN COMMUNITY HOWEVER
WITH THE WATER THAT'S COMING
FROM US WE ARE NOT ABLE TO GET
THAT WATER TO HELP OUR PEOPLE.
OTHER THINGS LANGUAGE THERE.
BILLS HAVE BEEN PASSED TO
CREATE LANGUAGE PROGRAMS FOR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND
THIS IS HELPING US. HOWEVER
IT'S DIFFICULT IF ANY OF YOU-
SPEAK MORE THAN ONE LANGUAGE
YOU KNOW THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
REALLY- A REVIVAL LANGUAGE A
REVERSE LANGUAGE SHIFT IS TO
IMMERSION. REAL QUICK ON THE
NUMBERS O MY PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BORDER OF THE
UNITED STATES AND MEXICO
THERE'S FOUR THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR. NINE
OF THAT FOUR THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY FORTY THREE WAS
TO SPEAK THE LANGUAGE. AND MOST
OF MARIN BAJA. SO IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS WHERE WE
CREATED COOLEY AYE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. FOR EDUCATION BECAUSE
OUR PEOPLE WERE NOT LEARNING
OUR STORY THEY WERE NOT
LEARNING OUR HISTORY IN THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR US. YOU SEE YOU
KNOW YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
MISSIONS AND HOW YOU LEARN ALL
THE INDIANS LOVED IT WHICH WAS
A YOU KNOW A- THE TOTAL FALSE.
WE'RE DIGITAL CULTURE WE'RE
TEACHING OUR HISTORY. AND NOW
WE WANT TO BRANCH OFF. WE
WANTED NO JUST LIKE WHAT YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW-
YOU KNOW GET THIS YOU KNOW. GET
OUR OUR OUR STORY. YOU KNOW
TEACHING THE STORY ABOUT THE
MISSIONS AND A GOLD RUSH IN THE
ATROCITIES THAT TOOK PLACE TO
THE PEOPLE IN THE- THE TRUE
STORY. SO I JUST WANT TO SHARE
THOSE FEW DAYS. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR. ME THE TIME TO SPEAK
TO ALL OF YOU. AND AS WE SAY IN
MY LANGUAGE. THE BUYER COME UP
SHORT. NOBLE MONEY WITHOUT NEW
YORK CON KNOW WHAT ARTICLE HON.
THE BILL LATER J. AKON RESUME
TO CREATE A WATCH OVER ALL OF
YOU AS YOU CONTINUE TO WALK
THIS PATH. THIS PAST OF TRUTH.
A STRAIGHT PATH. AND THE
CREATOR BLUSHING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M DOCTOR STANLEY
FOR THAT- DISCUSSION AND TRUE
FACTUAL DISCUSSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AND THE
SEVENTY EIGHT WHEN CULTURE THEN
WAS COMING FOR WHAT CULTURE WAS
LEFT BECAUSE OF THE CHASTISING
THE TOOK PLACE AGAINST PEOPLE
WITHIN THOSE BOARDING SCHOOLS
ARE SPEAKING THEIR OWN LANGUAGE
ONE OF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT FORWARD AND EXPLAINING THE
FEDERAL PROCESS OF HOW- SOME
TRIBES HAVE THE FOR
RECOGNITION- WITH US ALSO IS-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BLANCA RUBIO.
JUST JOINED US. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. YEAH THANK YOU I WAS-
WATCHING AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR THAT I WAS A FOURTH
GRADE TEACHER FOR ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS PRIOR TO COME TO THE
ASSEMBLY AND I WAS ONE OF THE
TEACHERS DAD HAD TO ASSIGN THE
MISSION PROJECT AND I ALWAYS
TRY TO EMPHASIZE TO MY STUDENTS
THAT- THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO PAY
COMMISSION THEY COULD PICK THE
TRIED THAT WAS NEAR THAT
MISSION AND TELL THEIR STORY
AND I A- MEXICAN AMERICAN I WAS
BORN IN MEXICO AND PRETTY WHEN
I WAS A KID SO I KNOW YOU KNOW
A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN THROUGH BUT- I'M GONNA
TALK TO MY STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
I'M ACTUALLY. YOU KNOW ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE OF AMERICA WE'RE
GOING. ANOTHER THING. CHAIR IS
THAT STORIES HISTORY BOOKS ARE
NEVER IN BY THE LOSER. IT'S
ALWAYS WEBER ONE. IT WOULD GETS
TO TELL THE STORY OF WHATEVER
IT MAY BE AND SOUL SO TRYING TO
CHANGE THAT I WOULD ASK THEM TO
DO RESEARCH ON THE TRIBE THAT
WAS NEAR WHATEVER THE MISSION
THAT THEY WERE CHOOSING- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE STORIES
ARE. ARE VERY MINIMAL YOU KNOW
WE NEED TO EXPERTS AND- TO GO
TO ACTUAL RESERVATIONS TO GET
THE TRUE STORY SO EVEN THE
RESEARCH THAT THEY WOULD DEAL
WITH STILL. YOU KNOW THEY WERE
FINE. THEY WERE GREAT- BUT SO I
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT AND ALSO
AS A SECOND LANGUAGE LEARNER I
UNDERSTAND. THE VALUE OF THE
IMMERSION. HOWEVER WHAT CAN WE
DO YOU KNOW IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO TRY AND HELP
REVIVE THOSE LANGUAGES I HAVE
BEEN TO SEVERAL RESERVATIONS
WHERE. WHERE THEY'RE DOING
THEIR OWN YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN CURRICULUM THEIR OWN
YOU KNOW FLASH CARDS ALL OF
THAT. BUT IS THERE ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO. HELP IN THAT.
TRYING TO REVIVE YOUR LANGUAGES.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
AS FAR AS LIKE TO NOTE
DEVELOPING CURRICULUM
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT AND AS I
SAID EARLIER CALIFORNIA'S SUCH
A DIVERSE STATE. IT IS IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO WORK
WITH THE NATIVE GROUPS IN THE
AREA TO GET AN ACCURATE I MEAN
AN ACTOR DEPICTION OF THE
HISTORY. AS FAR AS LANGUAGE
THIS IS A WHEN I THINK THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT COOLEY
AYE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS WE'VE
pACCREDITED CLASSES AND WE'VE
BEEN BRINGIN IN HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. SO WHAT THEY DO IS
RATHER THAN TAKING SPANISH OR
ANOTHER THEY'RE TAKING THEIR
OWN NATIVE LANGUAGE AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE LEARNING THAT AND AS
THE ACCOUNTS FOR NOT JUST FOR
HIGH SCHOOL CREDIT BUT ALSO FOR
COLLEGE CREDIT. SO BEING
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT CAN BE IN
SUPPORT OF A NATIVE EDUCATION.
AND GOING AND VISITING THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES IN THE
AREA YOU KNOW GIVING THEM A
VOICE. THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK
YOU. SO NO ONE COULD YOU I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- YOU
MENTIONED THAT THERE YOUR.
THERE'S POPULATIONS IN BAJA SO
AND THE COUNTRY OF MEXICO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER YOU CHAIR THE BY
THE BY NATIONAL COMMITTEE ON
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
CALIFORNIA AND MEXICO RIGHT AND
THIS IS THE NEW PRESIDENT OF
MEXICO I'M LOW JUST ESTABLISH
FOR THE FIRST TIME THE FIRST-
MEXICAN INDIGENOUS OUT
COMMISSION. THAT WOULD- ADDRESS
ISSUES ON CULTURE LANGUAGE-
TRADITION- AND REALLY-
RECOGNITION AND I I'D IDENTITY
AND I'M WONDERING IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THAT IN SOME WAY
WITH THE BY NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
IF I MAY IN SEPTEMBER- WE'RE
GONNA CONVENE TO THAT- WE'RE
GONNA CONVENE LEGISLATORS OF
BOTH SIDES OF THE BORDER. THE
CALIFORNIA- THE ALL THE U. S.
MEXICAN BORDER. AND LEGISLATORS
FROM THE FROM FROM THAT SIDE OF
THE BORDER AS WELL AND- I WILL
BE CHAIRING THAT THAT-
GATHERING AND- CERTAINLY THIS
MIGHT BE A TOPIC THAT I CAN
PRESENT- FOR DISCUSSION AT THE
SEPTEMBER THE GATHERING OF
LEGISLATORS FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE US MEXICAN BORDER- WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF DEVELOPING THAT
PROGRAM. AND WITH YOUR HELP I
WOULD VERY BE VERY HAPPY TO TRY
TO INCORPORATE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. FOR OUR SEPTEMBER
GATHERING. OF AND WHEN IT WAS
THANK YOU BOTH FOR- FOR YOUR
COMMENTS YOU KNOW JUST WHAT
YOU'RE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT-
I JUST WANNA SAY YOU DON'T WANT
TO LOSE ALTHOUGH THAT'S OUT
THERE ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
WELL MILLION BONTA. A GET US
OUT OF WILL WOULDN'T WHEN
CALLISTO IDEA FOR A BOILER THE
HINT THERE YEAH THE HAND IN THE
CAN A- LOCAL GUY BY BY KEY NEW
LOCAL TO ME. THE COCOPAH. THIS
IS A DOES OUR LOCAL NO
OBVIOUSLY. SO THESE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT YES WE CAN TALK
ABOUT WE DO WORK AND ALSO PASS
AND WE PASSED. THAT IS A BIG
PROBLEM THAT THAT WE HAVE AT
TIMES- OF- YOU KNOW WHAT ONE OF
THE THINGS YOU'RE AT THE
INTERNATIONAL BORDER CUT RIGHT
THROUGH. COOLEY AYE TERRITORY
SO THE YOU KNOW AND- SOME OF MY
RAMOS YOU KNOW WHEN WE GET
TOGETHER WHEN WE'RE SINGING AT
WICKS AND WE NEED SINGER SO
CALM. THERE'S MANY TIMES THE
REASON I LEARNED AS SPEAKS
SPANISH WAS I GO I'M A SINGER
AND I GO DOWN TO BOTHER TO GO
SOON- BUT I CAN TELL YOU GOTTEN
THAT LOTUS. TO SING IN THE
WICKS. AND IT IS IMPORTANT YOU
KNOW TO HAVE THAT TO HAVE THAT
CONNECTION. WE SAY OUR CULTURE
IS LIKE A NICE GUY A POT THAT
WAS SHATTERED. AND EACH
COMMUNITY HAS A PIECE OF THAT.
WHEN WE COME TOGETHER WE MAKE A
STRONG BUT YES I WOULD LOVE TO.
TO WORK WITH WHAT YOU. KNOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND- THE REALISTIC RIGHT OUT OF
THE BORDERS AND NOW WE SEE- THE
UNITED STATES WE SEE THE
BORDERS OF THEIR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER BACK IN
TIME THERE WAS NO BORDERS AND
PEOPLE FREELY ROAM. ON
FOLLOWING THE PLANT LIFE
FOLLOWING LIFE OF CULTURE
THAT'S THERE AND IT BY PEOPLE
AND NO DOES NOT KNOW THOSE
BORDERS RIGHT THE CULTURE STILL
EXIST. WHEN IT THANK YOU- FOR
THAT PRESENTATION OUR NEXT-
SPEAKER. IS MERRY LOPEZ KEY
FOR. A MEMBER OF THE SAN LUIS
REY BAND OF MISSION INDIANS AND
COMMISSIONER. AND SECRETARY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION. SHALL
SPEAK TO THE PERSPECTIVE OF NON
FAYE RECOGNIZED INDIAN TRIBES.
AND IT REALLY GOES- IN SYNC
WITH WITH YOUR PRESENTATION WE
TALK ABOUT BORDERS AND
BOUNDARIES WE SEE THOSE AREAS
NOW TODAY PHILLY RECOGNIZED BUT
LET'S TALK ABOUT. CALIFORNIA
INDIAN PEOPLE AS A WHOLE AS A
WHOLE THAT WHEN THE FIRST
EXPLORATION STARTED COME
THROUGH WITH THE RUSHED IN THE
SPANISH AND THEN THE MEXICAN
RULE. THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT A HIGH POPULATION
OF CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE THEN CAME
THE GOLD RUSH 80% DWINDLE DOWN.
SO MERRY LOPEZ- KEY FOR. WILL
BE ABLE. TO GUIDE US THROUGH
THAT DISCUSSION. FOR THAT'S NOT
A LOT. AND GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AT
CHAIRMAN RAMOS MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE- BEING INVITED
TO TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA NOT
REALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND
IT'S A LARGE GROUP- YOU'VE YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THAT THERE IS TO
ADD DISTINCT TYPE OF TRIBES IN
CALIFORNIA FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
AND NOT REALLY RECOGNIZED
OTHERS A HUNDRED AND NINE. OF
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND
THEIR SIXTY TWO NINE PHILLY
RECOGNIZE TRIBES I AM CURRENTLY
ON THE LIST OF TRIBES
MAINTAINED BY THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION.
AND SO NOT BARELY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES REPRESENT A THIRD OF
TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA. AND IT
BEGS THE QUESTION WHAT WHAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE AND WHY- BECAUSE
AT JUST AS AS YOU GREW UP
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA- YEAR
EXPERIENCE IS VERY COMMON-
SOMETIMES FAIRLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES DON'T KNOW THE EXISTENCE
OF NON BARELY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES- BEAN INVISIBLE. IS A
REALITY AND TRYING TO BREAK
THAT INVISIBILITY IS SOMETHING
TRIBES NOT FOR THE RECOGNIZE
TRIES WORK TOWARDS EVERY DAY.
AS YOU KNOW MY NAME IS MERRY
LOPEZ KIEFER- I EMPIRE WE
KITCHEN WHICH IS LISTEN YOU. I
AM A MEMBER OF THE SAN LUIS REY
BANNER MISSION INDIANS IT IS
ONE OF SEVEN THE SANYO TRIBES-
**** THERE SIX OTHER LISTEN
YOUR TRIBES IN OUR TERRITORY
WHO ARE ALL FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED. OUR TRIBE IS NOT
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED MAINLY
BECAUSE WE WOULD NOT LEAVE OUR
VILLAGE. OF KATJA WHICH IS WHY
YOU HAVE THE SALAS THREE
MISSION. THE KING OF THE
MISSIONS- IT WAS OUR VILLAGE
THAT MADE THEM WANT TO MAKE
THEIR FISH MISSION THERE AND.
IT WAS AN UNDERSTANDING WITH
THROUGH THE TREATY A TO MACULA
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO STAY
THERE- WHEN THE TRIBES
PARTICULARLY SALAS RACE SIGN
THAT TREATY A TO MACULAR WHICH
IS ALSO KNOWN AS TREATY QUE. IT
WAS EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE AND THE
TREATY'S FATE WAS NOT KNOWN TO
THE TRIBES UNTIL THEY WERE
UNSEALED IN NINETEEN OH FIVE.
IN ME BETWEEN THAT TIME YOU HAD
THE LANDS CLAIM ACT- YOU HAD
THE LAND COMMISSION COMING DOWN
THE TRIBES TO NOT MAKE LAND
CLAIMS BECAUSE WE HAD TREATIES.
ABOUT WHERE OUR LAND WISE AND
IT WASN'T UNTIL THE NINETEEN
HUNDREDS WHERE MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER WHO WAS THE CAPTAIN
OF OUR TRIBE AT OUR VILLAGE. WE
WERE FORCEFULLY EVICTED.
BECAUSE OR LAND WAS VERY
VALUABLE WE ARE ON THE COAST
IT'S NOW KNOWN AS THE CITY OF
OCEANSIDE. AND WE HAD. MANY
AGRICULTURAL LANDS THAT WE HAD
WORKED AND HAD NEVER LEFT WE
WERE THAT VILLAGE WAS OURS. OUR
HOME SINCE TIME IMMEMORIAL.
TODAY SALAS REYES- ANCESTRAL
TERRITORY WHERE WE ARE ARE
ACTIVELYENGAGED WITH THE-
GOVERNMENTS WITHIN THAT
TERRITORY IS COMPILED TEN CITY
OF OCEANSIDE CITY OF CARLSBAD
CITY THAN SYNODUS. THIS THE SAN
MARCOS ESCONDIDO AN
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES
WITHIN NORTHERN COUNTY SAN
DIEGO. AS A COMMISSIONER ON THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
pCOMMISSION I AM PRIVILEGED AND
THAT I GET TO INTERACT WITH A
LOT OF OTHER TRIBES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED NOT REALLY
RECOGNIZED BUT I HAVEN'T REALLY
DEFINED WHAT A FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBE IS- AT FAIRLY
RECOGNIZE TRIED HAS A SPECIAL
TRUST RELATIONSHIP WITH THE- US
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THEY ARE
RECOGNIZED AS SOVEREIGN
GOVERNMENTS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEY ARE
OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT FOR HOUSING EDUCATION
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND HEALTH
CARE. NOT FOR THE RECOGNIZED
TRIBES ARE NOT PROVIDED THESE-
RESOURCES- BECAUSE WE DO NOT
HAVE THAT TRUST RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IN
ORDER TO HAVE THAT TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NOT BARELY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD HAVE TO APPLY FOR FEDERAL
RECOGNITION PETITION
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT. TO DO SO WOULD
BE HAVING TO ENGAGE IN TO AN
INCREDIBLY FLAWED PROCESS THAT
IS ACTUALLY A DESIGNED TO NOT
ALLOW US TO BE BETTER
RECOGNIZED AND THIS WAS
EVIDENCED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN FINAL REPORT BY
THE ADVISORY COUNCIL ON
CALIFORNIA INDIANS TO THE US
CONGRESS- AND THAT WAS IN OVER
TWO DECADES AGO. IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. BUT GIVEN THAT I
TRIED TO JUST TO TERMINATION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO
PETITION FOR FEDERAL
RECOGNITION IS REALLY AN IS A
QUESTION ON THAT GOES TO THEIR
OWN SOVEREIGNTY- THEIR INHERENT
SOVEREIGN- DECISION TO DECIDE
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR PEOPLE.
YOU MAY NOT KNOW A FEDERAL
RECOGNITION APPLICATION. CAN
COST UP TO TWO MILLION DOLLARS
BECAUSE OF WHAT IS ENTAILED IN
IT THE NASA CITY FOR
PROFESSIONAL HISTORIANS
ANTHROPOLOGISTS ARCHAEOLOGISTS
GEOGRAPHERS JEAN GENEALOGISTS
ON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WON'T
TAKE YOUR WORD FOR IT. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE REGULATIONS
ARE WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT WILL
NOT ACKNOWLEDGE ITS OWN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S ROLE OR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIANS ROLE
IN THE GENOCIDE- OF CALIFORNIA
INDIANS SO TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY
WITH THOSE REGULATIONS. IT'S IN
AN IMPOSSIBLE FEAT SO. IT'S A
TRIBES DECISION TO FILE A
PETITION. IT WAS REALLY GOES TO
THEIR OWN- DECISION AS A
SOVEREIGN GOVERNMENT TO DECIDE
IF THAT'S IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THEIR PEOPLE BECAUSE- IF YOU
HAVE MONEY. WHAT IF YOU WANT TO
SPEND IT ON LANGUAGE PROGRAMS
CULTURAL PROGRAMS CREATING A
PLACE FOR YOU ALL TO GATHER
WHERE IT'S SAFE- OR OR DO YOU
WANT TO. GO FOR FEDERAL
RECOGNITION. HI IT'S AN
INCREDIBLY PERSONAL DECISION
FOR THE TRIED. SO ANY TIME YOU
SEE- REQUIREMENTS THAT TO BE
CONSIDERED A TRY BE HAVE TO BE
PETITIONING FOR FEDERAL
RECOGNITION- I JUST ASK YOU TO
TAKE THAT IN CONSIDERATION-
BECAUSE THAT MAY NOT BE IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE TRIBE. IT
DOESN'T MAKE THEM LESS OF A
TRIBE. ON SOME OF THE BIGGEST
STRUGGLES. FACING ON FAIRLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN MY OPINION
BECAUSE I CAN'T SPEAK TO
EVERYONE. PLEASE DON'T ASK ME
TO. BESIDES THAT THE PERVERSE
FEDERAL RECOGNITION- PROCESS IS
ONE NOT HAVING THE ECONOMIC
RESOURCES TO PRESERVE THE
CULTURAL AND SPIRITUAL
HERITAGE- AND LACKING
PROTECTION SPECIFICALLY I TO
KEEP THEM THEIR CHILDREN. AT IN
THEIR TRIBAL COMMUNITIES UNDER
THE INDIAN WELL FOR CHILD.
WELFARE ACT ALSO KNOWN AS A
BLACK. BEING ABLE TO. I'M GONNA
TACKLE THE FIRST BECAUSE THE
OTHER ONE IS PRETTY INVOLVED.
RIGHT NOW UNDER CALIFORNIA'S
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION THREE OH SIX POINT SIX
THE COURTS ARE ALLOWED-
DISCRETION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
A NOT REALLY RECOGNIZE TRIED
CAN BE INVOLVED IN DEPENDENCY
PROCEEDINGS. FOR A AT AN INDIAN
CHILD THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED
AN INDIAN. UNDER A GLASS IF BUT
FOR THE POLITICAL STATUS OF
THEIR TRIED. THIS DISALLOWS
TRIBES TO TRULY BE INVOLVED IN
SOMETHING THAT IS INHERENT TO
THEIR ABILITY TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN AND THE MEMBERS OF
THEIR TRIBES. SO ONE OF THE BIG
STRUGGLES IS WHY IS THAT
DISCRETIONARY. AND I KNOW JUST
FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE BY
BEING THE TRIBE'S CHIEF LEGAL
COUNSEL WE HAVE REQUESTED
INVOLVEMENT ON SEVERAL ISSUES
BUT BECAUSE IT IS THE COURTS.
DISCRETION IF WE ARE GOING TO
BE INVOLVED OR NOT WE ARE NOT.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE STRUGGLES
IS HOW HOW CAN WE STAY IN A
COMMUNITY. AND BE ABLE TO
PROTECT OUR MEMBERS AND OUR
CHILDREN- IF SUCH INVOLVEMENT
IS NOT AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT. AS
FAR AS. THAT THE LACK OF
ECONOMIC RESOURCES TO TRULY
PROTECT AND PRESERVE OUR
CULTURAL AND SPIRITUAL LEGACIES
AND- IS IT GOES TO. IT GOESBACK TO OUR HISTORY AS NON
RECOGNIZED TRIBES WE DON'T HAVE
A LAND BASE- WE HAVE A LOT OF
EMPTY PROMISES THAT WERE GIVEN
TO US THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
PLANNED- AND IT'S NOT A
COINCIDENCE THAT YOUR LARGEST
MATCH OF TOP METROPOLITAN AREAS
HAVE NO FAMILY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO- AND IT'S NO ACCIDENT
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
ALONG. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
COAST. AND WE WERE THERE- IN
FACT WE ARE STILL THERE. IN
FACT A MAJORITY OF NON FAIRLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES STILL LIVE
WITHIN THEIR ANCESTRAL
TERRITORY- WHICH I'M SURE YOU
CAN IMAGINE IS NO SMALL FEAT
GIVEN HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS TO
LIVE IN THE STATE- WE ARE
BUSINESS OWNERS WERE TEACHERS
ARE MUSICIANS. WE ARE SCHOLARS
WERE LAWYERS ON AND WE'RE
MECHANICS. WE ARE IN BAD IT-
WE'VE NEVER LEFT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE WE ALWAYS. HOW WE
LIKE TO PRESENT OURSELVES TO
THE GOVERNMENT'S THAT WE HAVE
TO WORK WITH. IN OUR CULTURE
LIVES THROUGH S. BECAUSE IT'S A
LIVING CULTURE. I AND SO IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE BE ABLE TO-
HAVE. LANGUAGE PROGRAMS IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WERE ABLE TO
RECLAIM WHAT HAD BEEN
FORCEFULLY TAKEN FROM US I
BELIEVE- DOCTOR RODRIGUEZ AND
MENTIONED. THAT THERE WAS A
LANGUAGE PROGRAM BUT ONLY FOR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES-
AND THAT'S A SHAME GIVEN THAT
WE ARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE HAVE SUCH A
HISTORY THAT'S FRAUGHT WITH
VIOLENCE AND TOWARDS OUR OUR
NATIVE PEOPLE BUT THAT'S THE
KIND OF PROGRAMS THAT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIA
INDIANS AND ALL TRIBES. BECAUSE.
I'M NOT REALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE
SHOULDN'T BE TREATED AS A
SECOND CLASS GOVERNMENT A
SECOND CLASS CITIZEN IF YOU'RE
A MEMBER OF A TRIBE- WE NEED TO
BE SEEN WE NEED TO BE HEARD.
BECAUSE OUR STORIES. AND OUR
HISTORY IS ARE THE SAME AS ARE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED-
COUNTERPARTS. WE ALL WERE.
VICTIMS OF ATTEMPTED GENOCIDE-
MY GRANDFATHER MY GREAT
GRANDFATHER WHO I MENTION WAS
OUR CAPTAIN WOULD TELL HIS
CHILDREN TELL HIS GRANDCHILDREN
DO NOT TELL ANYONE WHO YOU ARE
DON'T TELL THEM YOU'RE INDIAN
ARE YOU WILL BE TAKEN TO
BOARDING SCHOOL- AND THAT STOCK.
SO TO MY MOTHER AND HER SISTERS
WOULDN'T SAY BECAUSE THEY WERE
TOLD BY THEIR LEADER DON'T- AND
BECAUSE THEY HAD COUSINS WHO
WERE TAKEN- AND SO MY
GENERATION REPRESENTS THE FIRST
ONE. THAT CAN BE PROBABLY
INDIGENOUS BECAUSE MY
GRANDMOTHER WAS NOT ALLOWED TO
BE. AND WE FIGHT EVERY DAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PRESENCE IS
KNOWN BECAUSE I YOU SAID WE'RE
STILL HERE. SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES OF WHERE. WHERE WERE
CONFLICTED OR WE'RE WE'RE
BATTLING THE STRUGGLES IS THAT.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
PASSAGE OF AB FIFTY TWO-
REQUIRING LEAD H. SEEK RELIEF
AGENCIES TO CONSULT WITH TRIBES
EARLY ON IN THE PROCESS OF LAND
DEVELOPMENT SO THAT IF OUR-
TRIBAL CULTURE RESOURCES ARE
GOING TO BE NEGLEYIMPACTED
THERE'S A REAL CHANCE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT CAN BE MODIFIED TO
AVOID THAT IMPACT- IN
UNFORTUNATELY- TROUBLE
REPRESENTATIVES. IN ORDER TO
HAVE TRUE IMPACT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE MULTIPLE MEETINGS. WITH
OUR PLANNERS LEE AND DECISION
MAKERS- TROUBLE REPRESENTATIVES
ARE NOT COMPENSATED ARE THE
ONLY ONES AT THE TABLE WHO ARE
NOT BEING PAID FOR OUR
KNOWLEDGE OR EXPERIENCE- OUR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF. SECRET
MITIGATION MEASURES THAT ARE
CULTURAL CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
THAT ARE REQUIRED BY THE LAW.
THAT THEY PRESENT- THEY HAVE
INCLUDED IN THEIR DOCUMENTS- SO
WHETHER WE'RE MEDIAN UNDER SB
EIGHTEEN AB FIFTY TWO OR
EXECUTIVE ORDER BE TEN ELEVEN-
THE TRIBES ARE BEING
COMPENSATED SO IT'S AT YOUR OWN
ECONOMIC LOSS TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION SO A TRIBE. WHO'S
ALREADY. NOT IN WHO IS NOT
FLUSH WITH MONEY. HAS TO MAKE A
DECISION. IF THEY'RE GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS TO
PROTECT SACRED SITES. AND TAKE
THAT ECONOMIC LOSS OR THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO AND THEN HAVE TO.
BEING A DEAL WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES IN THE FUTURE. BUT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW THIS
BIT I'M GONNA SING YOU DON'T.
BUT MOST BARELY RECOGNIZE
TRIBAL MEMBERS ARE NOT ABLE TO
BE COMPENSATED BY THEIR TRIED.
AND SO THEY REPRESENT THEIR
TRIBES UNDER NO FEE ARE
VOLUNTARY BASIS- AND SO. THEY
HAVE TO HAVE DAY JOBS IN SO.
HUH AND WITH THERE ARE NO
SPECIFIC GRANTS AVAILABLE FOR-
THE FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES
CAN APPLY FOR A GRANT OR
FUNDING FOR TRIBAL HISTORIC
PRESERVATION OFFICERS- THERE'S
OTHER GRANTS I'M NOT SAYING
THEY'RE NOT COMPETITIVE GRANTS
TO GET THAT KIND OF FUNDING-
BUT THEY'RE JUST PLAINLY NOT
AVAILABLE TO NOT FREELY
RECOGNIZE STRIPES. AND SO. THEY
HAVE TO SACRIFICE THEIR OWN
LIVELIHOODS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS WORK- AND I KNOW I AM AS A
CALIFORNIA CITIZEN AS A
CALIFORNIA INDIAN WOMAN I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR SACRIFICES-
TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THE
LEGACY OF THEIR ANCESTORS-
ANOTHER CONCERN I KNOW. ANOTHER
CONCERN WE HAVE AND I JUST HAVE
TO GET THIS LAST ONE OUT AND
THAT YOU SHOULD BE AWARE OF- IS
UNDER THAT CALIFORNIA NATIVE
AMERICAN GRAVES AND
REPATRIATION ACT. AN UNDER NOW
PRO WHICH IS THAT THE FEDERAL
VERSION OF IS THE MAIN VERSION
AND NON FAIRLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES ARE NOT ABLE TO-
REPATRIATE THEIR ANCESTORS. I'M
LAST A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES SPONSORS THEM. AND
EATING THEN YOU HAVE TO GET THE
SECRETARY OF INTERIORS APPROVAL
OF FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
REPATRIATE YOUR ANCESTORS UNDER
CAL KNACK PRESS. NOT FOR THE
RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES ARE LIKE.
CALIFORNIA'S STATED THEIR
INTENT THEY WANT US TO HAVE OUR
ANCESTORS BACK BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE THEY BELONG THEY NEED TO
BE REBURIED. UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED WE HAVE NO LAND BASE.
OUR LANDS WERE VALUABLE THAT'S
WHY WE'RE NOT. IT IS WE HAD TO
BE AND THEY WERE TAKEN SO OUR
ANCESTORS CAN'T GO BACK TO MOST
LIKELY WHERE THEY CAME FROM
BECAUSE NOW IT'S NOT CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE IT'S BEEN DEVELOPED
IT'S NOT SAFE. SO WE NEED LAND
SO THAT WE CAN RE BURY THE
ANCESTORS THAT YOU WANT TO
REPATRIATE TO US AND WE WANT
YOU TO REPATRIATE TO S. SO THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I KNOW THAT
WE'VE DISCUSSED AT- WITH AS
PRESIDENT JANET NAPOLITANO OVER
AT THE UC SYSTEM. BECAUSE IT'S
COOL. AGAIN GREAT THAT WE'RE AT
A PLACE NOW WHERE THE STATE
WANTS TO REPATRIATE OUR
ANCESTORS TO US SO THAT THEY
CAN HAVE A PROPER BURIAL WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT- AND TAKEN
OFF THE SHELVES. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED A PLACE TO
PUT THEM AND IT NEEDS TO BE
SAFE- AND SO THAT THAT WAS A
CONCERN. I NEEDED TO BRING TO
YOU AS WELL AS- SAFE ACCESS. TO
LANDS FOR HARVESTING AND
GATHERING FOR OUR TRADITIONAL
PRACTICES OF NATIVE PLANTS-
RIGHT NOW THAT IS ONLY. TRULY
AVAILABLE TO FINALLY RECOGNIZED
TRIBES BECAUSE OF THE USE THE
FEDERAL PARKS AND TO BE ABLE TO
GATHER THE NOT REALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES ARE NOT
ALLOWED AND TO DO THAT- AND SO
WE ARE IN A POSITION WHERE WE
NEED TO WORK WITH STATE PARKS-
TO DO THAT AND THAT'S- THROUGH
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING AS
A PARTNERSHIP. I'M BUT I DON'T
WANT TO LEAVE IT ON A NEGATIVE.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA- HAS MADE
GREAT STRIDES IN A SALAS RAY
BAN EMISSION INDIANS IS VERY
GRATEFUL- FOR THOSE STRIDES TO
TRY TO. A RIGHT THE WRONGS OF
THE PAST BECAUSE TODAY AS A
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBE THAT'S
ON THE LIST MAINTAINED BY THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION WE HAVE. CONDUCTED
THOUSANDS OF GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATIONS WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES TO PROTECT OUR
CULTURAL RESOURCES AND SACRED
SITES. THANK YOU WE HAVE
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS TO
PROTECT THOSE SITES BECAUSE OF
CALIFORNIA LAW. AND WE ARE ABLE
TO- REBURY OUR ANCESTORS WITH
DIGNITY RESPECT- THROUGH THE
MOST LIKELY TO SENATE STATUTE
AS WELL AS CAL MAG PRADA. AND
WE'RE ABLE TO ENTER INTO A
MEMORANDUM OF AGREEMENT
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE AGENCIES
TO PRACTICE PER CARD- PROTECT
OUR SITES. WE CAN DO ALL OF
THIS BECAUSE WE'RE CALIFORNIA
INDIANS ON THAT LIST. AND
THERE'S OTHER TRIBES THAT DO A
LAND TRUST NOW SO. I SEE WHERE
WE CAN GO TOGETHER I JUST ASK
THAT YOU SEE YES AND EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE NOT FAIRLY
RECOGNIZED EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
NOT- GAMING TRIBES WERE NOT WE
DON'T HAVE LOBBYISTS. IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE MAKING A LOT THAT'S
GOING TO IMPACT US WE ASK THAT
YOU AT LEAST CHECK IN. OF
BECAUSE- WE ARE FINALLY AT A
POINT WHERE WE WANT TO BE
PROACTIVE AND NOT REACTIVE TO
THE LAWS SO AT THANK YOU AND
MAY CREATOR A LOOK AFTER YOU
AND GUIDE YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION THE
TIE IN THE HISTORY- GOING
THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CHALLENGES
TO THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE OF
FELL RECOGNITION TO NOT FOR A
RECOGNITION BUT THAT IN NO WAY-
SAYS THAT CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE
LESS. A CALIFORNIA PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THAT FEDERAL OR NOT
FEDERAL STATUS IS THERE IN TIED
INTO THE BOUNDARIES RIGHT THE
BOUNDARIES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
KNOWN TODAY AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THERE WAS NO
BOUNDARIES THAT'S WHERE THEY
HAVE BY TRAVEL BACK AND FORTH
IN INTO MEXICO. AND THE FEDERAL.
STATION OF TRIBES CAME FOR BUT
ALSO THERE WAS THE- DIFFERENT
FEDERAL TERMINATION POLICIES
THAT HAPPENED I'M IN AFFECTED
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
CHAIRMAN. RAYMOND HITCH CUT
FROM THE WILK RANCHERIA WILL
BE- SPEAKING TO THAT TOPIC AND-
CHAIRMAN HITCHCOCK IS OF THE ME
WALK IN THIS IN AND DESCENT HE
CURRENTLY SERVES AS A TRAVEL
CHAIRMAN AND CEO OF THE WILTON
RANCHERIA. THE ONLY A NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE AND SAT
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. MISTER
HITCHCOCK WILL DISCUSS THOSE
IMPACTS AND HOW HIS COMMUNITY
OVERCAME THOSE OBSTACLES. WOMAN
CHECKS IS COULD SHE A. EMMA.
WAS GOOD TO SEE CHAIRMAN RAMA
SIXTEEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS- WAY
SET RAMOS SEE ITS CAUCUS HE
SAID ON THE CHAIRMAN WHAT
RANCHERIA OF ME WHAT COMMISSION
ON THE SENATE. WHERE THE ONLY
FEDERAL RECOGNIZE TRY RIGHT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY RIGHT
RIGHT HERE ON THIS LAND SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT LANDING
KNOWLEDGE MEN AS WELL. SONY
GIVE ME A BRIEF HISTORY ABOUT
AND HO VIEW FEDERAL
TERMINATION POLICY ON
CALIFORNIA TRIBES. AND THIS IS
A OVERVIEW AND TRIBAL
PERSPECTIVE OF PERSONAL
STRUGGLES ANDKNOWLEDGE IS FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE- MY LANDS OF
THE HISTORY OF THIS AREA I MAY
SOUND LIKE A BROKEN RECORD WITH
SOME OF THE PAST TESTIMONY AT
YOU YOU'VE JUST HEARD WITH
THREE DIFFERENT PRESENTATIONS
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. FOR
THE CONTEXT TO EXPLAIN OUR
TRIBAL HISTORY AND HOW FEDERAL
TERMINATION POLICIES AFFECTED
CALIFORNIA TRIBES AND WILL
RANCHERIA IN PARTICULAR. JUST A
FEW BLOCKS FROM HERE CENTERS
FOR IT WAS ESTABLISHED IN THE
LATE EIGHTEEN THIRTIES. IT IS
LATE MUCH OF THE LOCAL NATIVE
POPULATION. TO WORK AT THE FORT
IN OTHER PROPERTIES THAT SUTTER
OWN IN THE VALLEY. IN EIGHTEEN
FORTY EIGHT JUST UP THE
AMERICAN RIVER ABOUT SIXTY
MILES TO THE EAST OF US. GOLD
WAS DISCOVERED AT SUTTER'S MILL.
THIS WAS THE BEGINNING OF THE
CALIFORNIA GOLD RUSH OF
EIGHTEEN FORTY NINE. WE HAVE
MANIFESTED AS THE SWEEPING
ACROSS THE CONTINENT WE HAVE
THE INTERCONTINENTAL RAILROAD
CONNECTING THE EAST COAST TO
THE WEST COAST. AND IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY WITH THE MASS IMMIGRATION
OF PEOPLE NEVER BEFORE SEEN
WITH DREAMS OF STRIKING IT RICH
XIN CRANING THE FERTILE LANDS
FOR THEIR HOMES. CALIFORNIA
BECAME THE THIRTY FOR STATE IN
THE UNION. IN. THIS MASS
IMMIGRATION THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. ESPECIALLY RIGHT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AT THE
EPICENTER. WAS THE ULTIMATE
DEMISE OF ARMY WORK IN MISSION
AND PEOPLE OF THIS AREA. ARE
FERTILE HUNTING GROUNDS AND
GATHERING SPOTS WERE EVER RUN
BY THE IMMIGRANTS. ARE TRIBAL
ANCESTORS HAD A VACATE THESE
AREAS THE CALL HOME AND VACATE
TO THE FOOTHILLS OF THE SIERRA
S. IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE AND
FIFTY TWO. EIGHTEEN TREATIES
WERE SIGNED BY REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
TRIBAL LEADERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. RIGHT HERE LOCALLY
TREATY J. IN PARTICULAR SIGNED
BY OUR ANCESTORS FROM THIS AREA
JUST FORTY FIVE MILES TO THE
SOUTHEAST ON THE FORKS OF THE
CONSUMERS RIVER. THIS TREATY
WOULD ESTABLISH TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND SQUARE
ACRES OR WELL OVER FOUR HUNDRED
SQUARE MILES OF RESERVATION.
FOR THE ME WHAT PEOPLE. THESE
TREATIES WERE NEVER RATIFIED BY
THE UNITED STATES SENATE. THIS
IS THE FIRST TERMINATION POLICY
OF CALIFORNIA IN MY OPINION.
OUR TRIBE'S RIGHT TO CO EXIST
WITH THE AND OUR ANCESTRAL
LANDS IN IN HARMONY WITH OUR
NEW NEIGHBORS THE IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE HAVING. IN
THE EIGHTEEN FIFTIES. FIRST
GOVERNOR CALIFORNIA WAS ELECTED
GOVERNOR PETER BURNETT. HE
CALLED FOR THE EXTERMINATION
AND ULTIMATE GENOCIDE OF THE
INDIGENOUS POPULATION UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA FOR BOUNTIES
FUNDED BY THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT AGAIN OUR TRIBAL
AFFILIATIONS THE ME WHAT THE
NATION ON THE PART WHEN TO. AND
THE MIGHTY PEOPLE RIGHT HERE AT
THE EPICENTER OF THAT SECOND
TERMINATION POLICY. IT SPREAD
ACROSS CALIFORNIA DECIMATING
ALL TRIBAL GROUPS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. BY THE EARLY
NINETEEN HUNDREDS MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION NATIVE
AMERICAN INDIGENOUS PEOPLES
PARRIS BECAUSE A US TERMINATION
POLICIES AND DECISIONS OF THE
PAST ALL THAT WIPING OUT OUR
HERITAGE AND OUR RACE. SO AT
THAT TIME TO DEAL WITH THE
LAMMAS INDIAN POPULATION THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEGAN
CREATING RANCHERIAS. THERE'S
FOR VARIOUS GROUPS OF LANDLESS
INDIGENOUS POPULATIONS AROUND
THIS AREA. WE SURVIVED THE
GENOCIDE THE PREVIOUS DECADES
OF OPPRESSION. SO IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT A RANCHERIA IT'S A
SMALL TRACT OF LAND GIVEN THE
SAME STATUS AS A RESERVATION.
BUT IT'S ON A MUCH SMALLER
SCALE. WILL RANCHERIA IN
PARTICULAR WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT IT WAS
THIRTY EIGHT ACRES. AS OPPOSED
TO THE FOUR HUNDRED SQUARE
MILES THAT TREATY J. OF
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE. WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED FOR THE TRIBAL PEOPLE.
ALL THE TRIBES THAT SURROUND US
IN THIS PART OF THIS AREA ARE
PART OF THE RANCHERIA ERA.
UNITED AUBURN INDIAN COMMUNITY
THUNDER VALLEY CASINO SHINGLE
SPRINGS BANNING ME WORKING THE
ANSWER RED HOT CASINO JACKSON
BANTER ME WORKING ITS JACKSON
RANCHERIA CASINO I AM THE ENEMY
WORKING IAN'S ONE INVEST
ABANDON ME LOOKING AS THEY HAVE
HARRIS RING CONN- NOT RAIN
CONCERT AT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SORRY
CHAIRMAN- AND- IT WILL
RANCHERIA BY RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. AND WE'VE GOT
ACROSS THE RIVER YESTERDAY HE
BàN IN THE WILL- MUCH GUY WHEN
TUNING IS EXCUSE ME AND THEY
HAVE THE CACHE CREEK CASINO.
THERE'S MANY OTHERS SO IN THE
LATE NINETEEN FIFTIES UNITED
STATES STARTED ANOTHER
TERMINATION POLICY IT WAS
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA RANCHERIA
ACT OF NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
EFFECTIVELY TERMINATED FORTY
ONE TRIBES INCLUDING RULED
RANCHERIA AND BY NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR MORE CALIFORNIA TRIES WERE
ADDED TO THE LIST OF
TERMINATION. WITH THIS
TERMINATION POLICY IN A
RANCHERIA ACTORS PROMISES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT OF
ROADS WATER SYSTEMS AND OTHER
SERVICES. EDUCATIONAL GRANTS
AND JOB TRAINING. LANCE TO BE
ASSIGNING DEEDED TO INDIVIDUAL
FAMILIES LIVING ON THE
RANCHERIAS WATER RIGHTS WERE
GONNA BE RELINQUISHED AND ALL
ACCESS TO FEDERAL INDIAN
PROGRAMS WERE TO BE TERMINATED.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NEVER
LIVED UP TO THEIR FEDERAL TRUST
RESPONSIBILITIES AS PROMISED
LEAVING TRIBAL MEMBERS LIVING
ON THE RANCHERIAS TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
SERVICES INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
OUTSTANDING PROPERTY TAX BILLS
FOR DECADES OF THE PAST FROM
THEIR RESPECTIVE COUNTIES TO
KEEP THEIR LAND ASSIGNMENTS. SO
IN EIGHTY THREE THERE IS A
HISTORIC LANDMARK CASE CALL THE
TELLY HARPER CASE THAT SUED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR NOT
FOLLOWING THROUGH WITH ITS
TRUST RESPONSIBILITIES AND
PROMISES. SEVENTEEN TRIBES
RESTORED TO FULL FEDERAL STATUS
FROM THAT CASE. WHAT RANCHERIA
WENT TO THAT COURT CASE BUT WE
COULDN'T THEY WOULD ALLOW US TO
ENTER ANY- ANY ACTION ON IT SO
THAT BEGAN OUR FIGHT FOR
RESTORATION FROM THAT HISTORIC
CASE. IT TOOK OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
NINE FOR WILL RANCHERIA TO BE
FULLY RESTORED TO FULL FEDERAL
RECOGNITION. WE ARE THE HUNDRED
NAY TRIBE IN HUNDRED OUT OF A
HUNDRED NINE TRIBES FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN. FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN MY LIFETIME. I
COULD ACTUALLY CHECK A BOX I
HATE SAYING THAT WITHOUT THE
QUESTION OF SOME FEDERAL AGENCY
THAT I'M NATIVE AMERICAN. I
ALWAYS KNEW MY ANCESTRAL
HERITAGE WHO I AM WAS NEVER
AFFORDED THE RIGHTS AND
PRIVILEGES WITHOUT THAT FEDERAL
RECOGNITION. ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE IN DENTAL SERVICES
EDUCATIONAL SCHOLARSHIPS AND
GRANT OPPORTUNITIES ONLY FOR
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBAL
MEMBERS HOUSING SERVICES AND
MANY OTHER BENEFITS. THIS IS
WHAT RESTORATION MENTOR TRIBE
IN GENERAL. BUT ON A LARGER
SCALE WE NOW HAVE THE ABILITY
TO CONTRACT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVRNMENT AGENCIES LIKE IHS
INDIAN HEALTH SERVICES FOR
PROGRAMS AND MEDICAL NEEDS FOR
TRIBAL MEMBERS CONTACT WITH HUD
HOUSING URBAN DEVELOPMENT FOR
HOUSING HOMELESS ISSUES
CONTRACT WITH EPA-
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
FOR BILLIARD ABILITY TO PROTECT
TO MONITOR PRECIOUS RESOURCES
AND OUR TRIBAL LANDS. IRVINE IN
AFFAIRS WE CONTRACT WITH TO
PROVIDE GOVERNMENTAL SUPPORT TO
WRITE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
INDIAN CHILD WELFARE
PROTECTIONS ELDER SERVICES AND
SUPPORT SOCIAL SERVICES FOR.
YOU SERVICES AND SUPPORT TRIBAL
COURT FUNDING TO PROVIDE OVER
MATTERS THAT DIRECTLY AFFECT
OUR TRIBE OR TRIBAL MEMBERS.
AND OVERALL SUPPORT TO
GOVERNMENTAL STRUCTURE. BEING
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED ALLOWS US
THE ABILITY TO RAISE REVENUE TO
LEVY TAXES ON FEDERAL TRUST
LAND. THE ABILITY THE NOTION
NEGOTIATE WITH ANY GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS AN EQUAL
SOVEREIGN NATION. THE RIGHT TO
GOVERN OURSELVES. SOVEREIGN
IMMUNITY AND SELF SUFFICIENCY.
SO ON ONE FOOT NOW WHEN THE
TRIBE WAS RESTORED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE WE WERE
LANDLESS WE HAD TO GO THROUGH A
PROCESS CALLED LAND INTO TRUST
THAT'S A NEED FOR PROCESS
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR TO REGAIN HISTORICAL
ANCESTRAL TERRITORY FOR THE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT OR HOUSING OR
TO CREATE A TRIBAL HOME BASE.
WE WERE FINALLY SUCCESSFUL IN A
DECISION ON THE LAST DAY OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IN JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. WE
FINALLY PUT THIRTY SIX ACRES OF
LAND IN A TRUST FOR THE TRIBES.
NEARLY SIXTY YEARS AFTER BEING
TERMINATED AND LANDLESS. SO
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THAT. THE
GENERATIONAL PROBLEMS OF THAT
SYSTEMIC FROM THOSE TERMINATION
POLICIES THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT'S ON CALIFORNIA
TRIBES ON OUR NATIVE PEOPLE.
OUT OF ALL THE ETHNIC GROUPS
NATIVE AMERICANS HAD THE WORST
STATISTICS AND MANY NEGATIVE
CATEGORIES SOMETIMES WERE NOT
EVEN COUNTED AT ALL AND-
THERE'S A LACK OF TRUST OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. LACK OF
TRUST AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. OUR CULTURE OUR
WAYS ARE LANGUAGE WAS ALL BUT
STRIPPED AWAY OUR IDENTITY OF
WHO WE ARE. WE'RE ALL BUT
DESTROYED. OUR ANCESTRAL LANDS
ALL BUT STONE AWAY WITH SO MANY
BROKEN PROMISES OF TERMINATION.
SO IN CONCLUSION WHEN YOU SEE
LEGISLATION COME ACROSS YOUR
DESK OR YOU ASKED TO VOTE ON
LEGISLATION OR INITIATIVES THAT
INVOLVES TRIES ON GAMING ON
EDUCATION ON ANY CHILD WELFARE
ON HOUSING AND ANY ANOTHER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT FACE OUR
TRIBES. I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA AND
HOW WE GOT HERE. I WANT YOU TO
BE SUPPORTIVE OF TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY. TO RECOGNIZE OUR
LOSS OF ANCESTRAL HOMELANDS.
AND BEAT SUPPORT OF OUR QUEST
TO RESTORE THOSE TRIBAL LANDS
ONE ACRE AT A TIME. AND I WANT
YOU TO NOT FEEL SORRY ABOUT THE
PAST BUT HOW YOU AS LEADERS OF
THIS GREAT STATE TO WORK SIDE
BY SIDE WITH TRIBES TO REALIZE
A BETTER TOMORROW. TO
UNDERSTAND THE REAL HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA TRIBES AND WHAT
TERMINATION POLICIES DID TO US
AS A RACE AS TRIBAL NATIONS AND
WORK TOGETHER TO CHANGE THESE
HORRIBLE POLICIES INTO HOPE IN
SHADES FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
TING INCOME. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT- PRESENTATION. AND
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'VE HAD-
UP TO THIS POINT. WITH THE
DIFFERENT PRESENTERS- A CATCHER
REASONING VOLLEY- DOCTOR
STANLEY RODRIGUEZ- MERRY LOPEZ
KEY FOR AND CHAIRMAN HITCHCOCK
BRING INTO THE PERSPECTIVE OF.
THE HISTORY OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE AS A WHOLE AND- REALLY.
TRYING TO EDUCATE THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT WHEN. THERE'S
AN INADVERTENT DISCOVERY OF
NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS REMAINS
THAT ARE CLOSE TO A FAIT
RECOGNIZED TRIBE MOST LIKELY
DESCENDANTS ARE NOTIFIED. BUT
ALSO WHEN REMAINS ARE FOUND IN
POPULATED CITIES SUCH AS LOS
ANGELES OAKLAND SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE THERE IS NO FERRY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES DOESN'T MEAN.
THAT THERE ISN'T TRIBES THAT
ARE THEY'RE WILLING TO- REBURY
RESPECTFULLY THEIR ANCESTORS SO
AN ANCESTORS OF CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE AREN'T COVERED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS DISCUSSION
THAT WE'RE HAVING TALKS ABOUT
IN TRYING TO BRING THAT
KNOWLEDGE THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE INADVERTENT DISCOVERY
OF NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS.
THAT IT INCLUDES ALL CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE FROM THE FEDERAL
RECOGNITION TO THE NON
RECOGNITION TO THE TERMINATION
ACT THAT NOW HAS A FEDERAL
COMMISSION MOVING FORWARD. BUT
YET WE KNOW AS IT WAS ALLOCATE
ME PUT THAT FEDERAL RECOGNIZE
RESERVATIONS AREN'T IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AREN'T ON THE
COAST RIGHT ART IN AREAS THAT
ARE BEING DEVELOPED. SO THIS
WHOLE DISCUSSION IS REALLY
CENTER AROUND. THAT DISCUSSION
OF THE INVERTED DISCOVERY AND
HONORING OUR ANCESTORS OUR
ANCESTORS OF MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR VOICES PUT A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD OF OTHER
ARCHAEOLOGISTS DIRECTORS OF
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT WHEN THAT
COMES TOGETHER AND WE SAT
THROUGH A LOT OF COMMISSION
HEARINGS TOGETHER. WE SEEN THAT.
LEVERAGE I BELIEVE THESE TYPES
OF HEARINGS THESE TYPES OF
DISCUSSIONS IS PUTTING US BACK
TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE. IN THE
NEXT SPEAKER- THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE COME UP WILL PUT ALL THAT
TOGETHER- INTO SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN- DEFINITELY- MOVE
FORWARD ON. AND THAT'S LARA
MARANDA WHO'S THE CHAIR OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION SO LET'S CLEAR THE
WAY AND LET LAURA COME UP. IN
THANK YOU LARA FOR. AGREED TO
COME IN LARA IS GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT DEFINING
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES FOR INCLUSIVITY. AND.
LARA AROUND AS A MEMBER OF THE
CHINA BAND IN THE SANYO INDIANS
IN NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION CHAIR. SHE WILL HELP
US UNDERSTAND HOW TO BE
INCLUSIVE AS WE WORK TO DEFINE
THE CUT WHAT CONSTITUTES A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBE THANK YOU. SURE WOMEN
MARANDA FROM THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERE HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THAT
INTERACTION- ASSEMBLY MEN
CHAIRMAN ALL OF YOUR TITLES- I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR. THE FORMATION OF THIS
SELECT COMMITTEE- JUST THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT- I'VE BEEN%
WORKING IN THE AREA OF.
LEGISLATIVE WORK ON CULTURAL
RESEARCHERS PROTECTION SACRED
SITES PROTECTION- HUMAN REMAINS
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS- I'M A
LAWYER A TRIBAL LAWYER WORK FOR
MY TRIBE BUT I'VE ALSO WORKED
FOR A NUMBER OF OTHER TRIBES.
AND HAVE BEEN FORTUNATE TO BE A
TECHNICAL CONSULTANT TO-
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE ON
A NUMBER OF BILLS CONCERNING
SACRED SITES- THAT MOST LIKELY
DESCENDANTS STATUTE OF- WHEN
HUMAN REMAINS ARE FOUND. AND
THE KNACK FOR STATUTES THAT ARE
THE CALIFORNIA BASED-
REPATRIATION STATUTES I WAS
ALSO ASSEMBLYMAN GATOS
TECHNICAL ADVISER ON AB FIFTY
TWO WHICH WAS PRETTY MUCH THE
MOST RECENT. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- VERY- PRO
PROTECTION OF TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES AND THE ESTABLISHMENT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN STATE LAW
OF TRIBES AS GOVERNMENTAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE ENTITLED TO
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ON ISSUES THAT
AFFECT THEIR CULTURAL
RESOURCES- WE ALSO GOT. TRIBAL
CULTURE RESOURCES IN THE SEA
QUEST THE STATE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT AS A NEW CATEGORY
OF RESOURCES THAT DESERVE
PROTECTIONS JUST LIKE
BIOLOGICAL RESOURCES WETLANDS
AND OTHER RESOURCES THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT CALIFORNIA. SO THAT'S
A LITTLE BIT OF MY HISTORY- AND
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERTISE THAT I
BRING. TODAY I'M I'M WEARING
THE HAT. AS NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION CHAIR. AND
JUST SORT OF WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT- SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
WE ARE PRESENTLY DEALING WITH
AND THAT ARE SORT OF FEELING
LIKE THEY'RE ON THE HORIZON FOR
THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE AND-
ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS HAS BEEN A
BIG SUPPORTER OF WARNING TO
ASSIST WITH THAT. THE
COMMISSION. THE. THE COMMISSION
JUST LAKE WE'RE ENVISIONING
THIS COMMITTEE CAN BE A GREAT
RESOURCE TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE MEMBERS ON ISSUES OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN CULTURE SO
THE HERITAGE COMMISSION HAS-
BEEN EXISTENCE FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS- ALMOST FORTY YEARS WE
CELEBRATED OUR- THE FORTIETH I
THINK WAS OUR FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY ORDER A COUPLE
YEARS AGO YEAH. TONY JUST MORE
THAN THAT. YEAH I AM BUT BUT
THIS IS A REAL IT FORTY YEARS
IS A LONG TIME BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IN THE CONTEXT OF
OVERALL HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA
IT'S NOT THAT LONG- AND THAT
WAS THE TIME WHEN THE AND I'M
SURE YOU I THINK AT THIS
COMMITTEE RECEIVED A BRIEFING
ON SORT OF THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE COMMISSION. MAYBE AT THE
LAST HEARING- BUT BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF JUST CONTEXT HERE
AND TIMING IT WAS ONLY THE
FORTY YEARS AGO THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA STARTED
RECOGNIZING THROUGH STATE LAW
THAT NATIVE AMERICAN REMAINS
DESERVED PROTECTIONS SO WE'RE
TALKING VERY RECENT RECENT
HISTORY AND THROUGH THAT THAT
PIECE. OF US HAVING IS THAT-
VAST AMOUNT OF KNOWLEDGE OF THE
LAST FORTY YEARS OF ASSISTING
TRIBES WITH THESE ISSUES. THE
COMMISSION ALSO STANDS AS A
RESOURCE TO ALL OF YOU- ON ON
ISSUES OF SACRED SITES
PROTECTION AND CULTURAL ISSUES
FOR TRIBES AND I JUST WANTED
OFFER THAT AS WELL BECAUSE PART
OF OUR COMMISSION DUTIES IS
ACTUALLY TO PROVIDE-
RECOMMENDATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
ON CERTAIN ISSUES SURROUNDING
CERTAIN SUBJECTS THE
SURROUNDING SACRED PLACES. AND
REPATRIATION. I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IT A SORT OF CURRENT
ISSUE AND IT THEY'RE BOTH
RELATED A ONE OF THEM IS- WET
AND ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS HAD-
IDENTIFIED IS THE DEFINITION OF
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES. AND
FOR THE CONTEXT HERE FOR
PURPOSES OF AND WE HAD THIS
THIS ARC OF HISTORY OF THE
UNIQUE STATUS AND HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND HOW TRIBES HAVE
BEEN REMOVED FROM THEIR LANDS
AND HOW THEY'VE BEEN FORCEFULLY
EVICTED AND REMOVED AND THEIR
TIES TO THEIR CULTURE HAD BEEN
FORCIBLY REMOVED ALTHOUGH I
FEEL LIKE THE TRIBES HAVE DONE.
THE TREMENDOUS AND IT'S A
TESTAMENT TO US WERE ALL
SURVIVORS OF CULTURAL TRAUMA
THAT WE'VE CAPPED OUR
TRADITIONS AND CULTURES ALIVE-
BUT IT'S BEEN AT- AT THE
FIGHTING OF ICE BEING CUT OFF
FROM THEM. SO THAT IN THAT
CONTEXT THAT WE'VE HAD I WANT
TO JUST TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
SORT OF MODERN DAY. PROBLEMS OR
CHALLENGES THAT TRIBES ARE
FACING BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE
HISTORY AND- ONE OF THOSE
THINGS IS BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THE STATUS AND THE STANDING AND
STATE LAWS TO THEN GO ON AND
PROTECT YOUR CULTURE
RESEARCHERS YOUR SACRED SITES
IN YOUR HUMAN REMAINS. ANDMARY
HAD TOUCHED BRIEFLY ON SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT A NON
RECOGNIZED TRIBE MIGHT HAVE
AND- RECOGNIZED TRIBES HAVE
SIMILAR ISSUES- SO IN TALKING
ABOUT. THESE THINGS IT'S THE
DEFINITION OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES AND THEN ALSO IN CONTEXT
OF REPATRIATION AND IN
PARTICULAR THE CALIFORNIA KNACK
PER BILL ARE ARE THE CALIFORNIA
NOW PRO LAW AND AS IT RELATES
TO REPATRIATION OF HUMAN
REMAINS- THAT THE REPATRIATION
OF HUMAN REMAINS A PROTECTION
OF HUMAN REMAINS. IS A PRETTY
CURRENT ISSUE RIGHT NOW IN THE
RECENT YEARS THERE'S BEEN- A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS BY TRIBES OF
THEIR ABILITY TO USE THE
FEDERAL LAW- AND THE STATE LAW
TO. IT TO ENABLE RICK THESE
INSTITUTIONS AND MUSEUMS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- NAMELY HE
UC SYSTEM TO REPATRIATE REMAINS
THAT ARE BEING HOUSE THERE. MY
COMMISSION MY COMMISSION HAS A
VERY UNIQUE ROLE WITH REGARD
TO- THE STATE REPATRIATION AND
THE FEDERAL PATRIATION LAW WE
ARE ACTUALLY- LOOKED AT AS- THE
OVERSIGHT GROUP- THAT WE HAVE
THE BOB THE OBLIGATION AND THE
ROLES TO ASSIST IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF REPATRIATION
WE ACTUALLY CAN ORDER
REPATRIATION OF HUMAN REMAINS
AND CULTURAL ITEMS BY STATE
THAT ARE HOLDING THEM. AND WE
ALSO CAN HELP IMPLEMENT THE
FEDERAL LAW WE CAN ACTUALLY
REPORT IF WE THINK THAT STATE-
INSTITUTIONS AND MUSEUMS ARE
NOT FOLLOWING THE FEDERAL AND
STATE LAW WE CAN REPORT TO THE
FEDERAL OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
AND THEN WE CAN BRING PEDAL TO
THE PENALTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR NON COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
THE REASON THIS IS THE- AND
THIS IS FOR PURPOSES OF OUR
OTHER WE HAVE TO A COUPLE OF
OTHER KEY ROLES ONE OF THEM AS
WE CAN HELP MEDIATE DISPUTES IF
THAT IF THE TRIBES THAT ARE
TRYING TO CLAIM REPATRIATION OF
THEIR ANCESTORS OR THEIR TRIBAL
CULTURAL RESOURCES ARE HAVING
ISSUES. WITH THE MUSEUMS ARE
INSTITUTIONS WE CAN STEP IN AND
MEDIATE DISPUTES WE CAN ASSIST
WITH- OF IDENTIFICATION OF
TRIBES AND GROUPS TO TALK TO
WITH THE MUSEUMS AND
INSTITUTIONS SO WE PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN FACILITATING THIS. AND
I DID THIS TO BACK UP A LITTLE
BIT SO CALIFORNIA NOW PRESS. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE I MEAN I
THINK YOU ALL ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT IT WAS IMPLEMENTED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. AND THEN
ASSEMBLYMAN STEINBERG AUTHORED
THIS BILL AND IT WAS MAINLY TO
DEAL WITH THE UNIQUE.
CIRCUMSTANCES OF CALIFORNIA
INDIANS IN THAT THEY WEREN'T
ABLE TO USE THE FEDERAL LAW. TO
REPATRIATE THEIR HUMAN REMAINS
FROM THESE INSTITUTIONS. AT
THAT TIME THE UC WAS ONE OF THE-
I GUESS VOLATORS AND
UNFORTUNATELY UC BERKELEY STILL
HOLDS AS OF A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN REPORT NINE THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED SETS OF HUMAN
REMAINS. OF THOSE THEY ARE
SAYING THAT 86% OF THOSE THEY
DON'T KNOW THE CULTURAL
AFFILIATION AND FOR PURPOSES OF
THE LAW THAT MEANS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO REPEAT TREAT THEM
BECAUSE THEY CLAIM THAT THEY
DON'T KNOW WHO THEY ARE
DESCENDED FROM. THEY ALSO HAVE
THIRTEEN THOUSAND THIS WAS IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
REPORT ON- UC CAMPUS CAP IT
KNACK PER ACTIVITIES THAT THEY
ALSO HAVE THIRTEEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE-
ASSOCIATED FUNERARY OBJECTS AND
THOSE- THAT'S THE TECHNICAL
LEGAL TERM BUT- FROM A TRIBAL
PERSPECTIVE WE THINK OF THOSE
IS BURIAL GOODS AND GRADE GOODS
IN SACRED ITEMS- THEY HAVE OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND OF THOSE
ITEMS. OF WHICH 72% THEY SAY
ARE CULTURALLY UNAFFILIATED
MEANING THEY DON'T KNOW WHO TO
REPEAT THEIR REPATRIATE THEM TO
OR THEY SAY THAT THERE ISN'T AN
EXISTING PRESENT DAY GROUP.
THAT CAN SHOW THAT THERE
CULTURALLY AFFILIATED WITH
THOSE ITEMS THIS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM- BERKELEY HAS AT THE
PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM HAS ONE OF
THE LARGEST NAGS PRO
IMPLEMENTED COLLECTIONS IN THE
NATION. AND THIS IS ON A SCALE
AND THE PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM
HAS ADMITTED THAT THEY'VE SAID
WE DON'T WE WE'RE NOT A CAN TO
OTHER EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
IN CALIFORNIA. OUR COLLECTIONS
ARE ON A SCALE THAT'S
EQUIVALENT TO THE AMERICAN
MUSEUM OF NATURAL HISTORY OR
THE SMITHSONIAN WE'RE TALKING A
LARGE COLLECTION HERE THAT HAS
A UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE OF HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE TREATED HOW WE
CAN A TACKLE THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE PRESENTLY THERE ARE
NUMBER OF TRIBES THAT ARE
TRYING TO INVOKE THE STATE CAL
KNACK PRATT TO GET THESE THINGS
FOR PATRIOT IT BECAUSE THE
STATE CAL NOW PER ADDS SOME
EXTRA ELEMENTS OF THE FEDERAL
LAW DOESN'T ADD THAT RECOGNIZES
THIS WHOLE ARC OF UNIQUE.
TERMINATION AND GENOCIDE
HISTORY THAT YOU'VE HEARD OF
THERE'S- THERE'S AN AND A PIECE
ABOUT STATE LANDS AFFILIATION
AND THAT REALLY GIVES THE
ABILITY FOR THESE INSTITUTIONS
TEND NOT HAVE A STRICT
CHRONOLOGICAL AND CONNECTION
BUT TO HAVE AN OVER ALL-
UNDERSTANDING BASED ON TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE IN HISTORY- OF THEIR
TIED TO THESE ITEMS. MAKING IT
EASIER FOR THEM TO SHOW THEIR
CULTURAL FILIATION AND FOR THEM
TO THEN RETURN HOME AND GET
REPATRIATED- AND THE ISSUE IN
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE AND UP
UNTIL NOW REALLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NOW PER IS THAT
ALTHOUGH IT HAD SOME GREAT
LANGUAGE AND IT WAS NEVER
FUNDED. AND IT NEVER REALLY GOT
IMPLEMENTED- AND THE
COMMISSION- WE GET WE ARE
RECEIVING- REQUEST PRESENTLY TO
START IMPLEMENTING THAT LAW AND
THE COMMISSION WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT TO GET THAT GOING-
THE PRESENT DAY ISSUE IS THERE
ARE THERE SOME THINGS SENSE THE
LAW IS. A LITTLE DATED AND THE
FEDERAL LAW HAS BEEN UPDATED
SENSE THEN THAT THERE ARE SOME
LANGUAGE THINGS THAT. IT NEED
TO BE BROUGHT UP TO DATE- AND
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT AT THIS
POINT AND ONE OF THEM IS THE
DEFINITION O CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES. THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT- WHAT IS PRESENTLY BEING
PROPOSED IS THIS INCLUSIVE
DEFINITION OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES. AND I JUST WANTED TO
GIVE SOME BACKGROUND ON THAT TO
SET SOME CONTACTS FOR HOPEFULLY
SOME SOME- CHANGES AND
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES THAT ARE
GOING TO BE COMING- SOON ABOUT
THAT. NOW WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WHEN I'M TALKING ABOUT IN
THIS CONTEXT CALVET DEFINITION
CALIFORNIAN IN TRIBES I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT FEDERAL
RECOGNITION OR STATE
RECOGNITION OR- ANY ENTITY ANY
STATE ENTITY BEING THE
LEGISLATURE OR THE HERITAGE
COMMISSION OR ANY STATE AGENCY
DESIGNATING WHO IS INDIAN AND
WHO IS NOT INDIAN OR WHO IS A
TRIBE AND WHO IS NOT A TRIBE- I
AM BECAUSE THAT IS A FEDERAL
RECOGNITION PROCESS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
HAVE A ROLE IN. SOWHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT IS DEFINING WHO
IS A CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBE
FOR PURPOSES THAT BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE LAWS
THAT GIVE TRIBES IN NEED OF
PEOPLE THE ABILITY TO PROTECT
THEIR RESOURCES REPATRIATE
THEIR RESOURCES PROTECT THEIR
SACRED SITES SO THIS IS ALL
ABOUT THAT AND CURRENTLY THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION HAS A
CONTACT LIST- THAT. THAT WE
DEFINE AS CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES AND THAT CONTACTLESS HAS
BASICALLY BEEN ENOUGH FACTS.
SENSE. TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF A OF A LAW
CALLED SB EIGHTEEN WHICH WERE
AMENDMENTS INTO THE PLANNING
LAW THAT ALLOWED TRIBES TO
CONSULT WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABOUT PROTECTION A PLATE SIT
THEIR SACRED SITES WINS CITIES
AND COUNTIES UP DID THEIR
GENERAL PLAN UPDATED THEIR
GENERAL PLANTS. THEN THEY WOULD
CONSULT WITH TRIBES TRIED TO
TELL THEM WHERE SENSITIVE AREAS
WERE AND HOW THEY COULD DO
PROACTIVE PLANNING TO AVOID-
PROTECT THESE SITES. AND AT
THAT TIME THE BILL THE
LEGISLATURE PUT INTO PLACE A
PROCESS- TO DEFINE OKAY WHO
WERE THE ELIGIBLE TRIBES THAT
ARE GONNA BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS
CONSULTATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT THEIR
SACRED PLACES. WE KNOW THE
UNIQUE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA IT
CAN'T JUST BE RACKING FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES- AND I WAS
ONE OF THE TECHNICAL PEOPLE-
ALONG WITH IT IT AT MANY OTHERS
THAT PUSHED FOR AN OVER
INCLUSIVE DEFINITION. TO
RECOGNIZE THE UNIQUE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO WHAT THE
PROCESS THAT ENDED UP BEING
CODIFIED WAS THAT THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION AS
AN EXPERT. IN CULTURAL
RESOURCES TRIBAL RESOURCES-
SENSE THE EARLY EIGHTIES WOULD
BE THE STATE AGENCY THAT WOULD
THEN TAKE ON THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF CREATING THIS CONTACTLESS
FOR CONSULTATION PURPOSES AND
WE DID THAT. AND THAT THEN GOT
CARRIED INTO- AB FIFTY TWO
WHICH IS THE THAT LOG THE
AMENDMENTS AND TO SEEK WHAT.
AND SO WE ALSO DESIGNATE- WE
USE THAT SAME CONTACT LIST THAT
WE DESIGNATE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHICH TRIBES THEY
ARE TO CONSOLE WITH ON
PROTECTION OF TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES WHEN THEY'RE IMPACTED
BY. ANY DEVELOPMENT THAT
SUBJECT TO SEA QUEST. SO THE
COMMISSION. AND IN EVEN BEFORE.
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN IDENTIFYING
WHAT'S CALLED MOST LIKELY
DESCENDANTS UNDER THE NADIR
UNDER THAT NATIVE AMERICAN
HUMAN REMAINS LAW- SO. THE
COMMISSION HAS THE FORTY YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE IN IDENTIFYING
WHOSE CULTURALLY AFFILIATED.
AND TERMS OF WHO'S ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CARING AND THAT
INTO THE REPATRIATION STATUTES.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE- IT JUST AS
BACKGROUND- BUT WHEN WE WENT
THROUGH THE DISCUSSIONS OF HOW
DO YOU DEFINE TRIBES FOR
PURPOSES OF THE STATE LAWS.
THERE WAS TALK IN THE BEGINNING
ABOUT ACTUALLY TRYING TO WRITE
A DEFINITION OF CALIFORNIA
INDIAN TRIBES AND THE
LEGISLATURE CREATING THAT
DEFINITION BACK IN THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS AND IT WAS
QUICKLY REALIZED THAT- DID THE
TRIBES DIDN'T WANT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SAYING WHO WAS A
TRIBE AND WHO WASN'T. AND THE
STATE OF THE LEGISLATURE DID
NOT REALLY WANT THAT TASK
EITHER IT'S NOT IT'S NOT UP TO
THEM IT'S AT ITS OUT OF THAT
PER VIEW SENTENCE OF FEDERAL
FEDERAL ISSUE BUT HOW THE
COMMISSION DOES IT IS THAT WE
IT'S BASICALLY THE TRIBES SELF
IDENTIFY WHO THEY ARE AND WHERE
THEIR TERRITORIES ARE. AND WE
DO THAT BASED ON TWO MAIN
CRITERIA ONE IS THAT I AM
SHOWING THAT THEY ARE DESCENDED
FROM A HISTORICAL CALIFORNIA
TRIBE AND THE OTHER IS THAT
THEY HOLD THEMSELVES OUT AS A
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY
OPERATE THAT WAY. AND IF THEY
CAN SHOW THOSE THINGS AND SHOW
AND IT'S SUBMIT THOSE
DOCUMENTS- THE COMMISSION PUTS
THEM ON THE LIST OF WHO IS A
CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBE FOR
PURPOSES OF YOU KNOW
CONSULTATION ON THESE CULTURAL
RESOURCES ISSUES AND WE'VE NOT
HAD ANY COMPLAINTS THAT THAT
PROCESS ISN'T WORKING. M. IT'S
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE EVERY DAY
SORT OF YOU KNOW ISSUES OF THAT
OF ADMINISTRATING THIS AND
WE'VE BEEN UNDER FUNDED FOR SO
LONG BUT THE OVERALL FEEDBACK
THAT THE COMMISSION HAS
RECEIVED IS THAT THIS PROCESS
IS WORKING FOR THE CONSULTATION
PLEASE SO WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WANTING TO CARRY THAT THROUGH
TO THE REPATRIATION PIECE-
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. THE
REPATRIATION LAW IT IS JUST A
WOEFULLY OUT OF DATE AND THERE
IS AN EXISTING DEFINITION
UNFORTUNATELY AND THE LAW AS IT
EXISTS THAT IS JUST. IT'S NOT
EVEN COMPLAIN WITH FEDERAL LAW
AT THIS POINT IT'S JUST AN OLD
DEFINITION SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
BRING THAT UP TO DATE- IT'S A
WAY THAT. WE CAN HELP GET THE
ANCESTORS HOME QUICKER- BY OVER
IT BY BEING INCLUSIVE IN OUR
DEFINITIONS OF WHO WE CONSIDER
OUR CALIFORNIA INDIAN TRIBES
FOR PURPOSES OF STATE LAW. WE
WANT TO. AND IN DO THAT IN A
WAY THAT GETS THESE ANCESTORS
HOME- SO I'D- MOVE. THE REASON
FOR GIVING YOU KNOW ALL THAT
BACKGROUND. IS TO IS TO SET UP
THIS PIECE OF HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS THAT- WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
AN INCLUSIVE DEFINITION WITH-
THE COMMISSION AS THEENTITY
THAT HAS THE EXPERTISE TO WORK
WITH TRIBES TO FACILITATE THESE
TYPES OF DISCUSSIONS AND TO
ENABLE- CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
GET THE ANCESTORS BACK HOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SHOWN
AROUND UP IN YOU YOU TOUCHED ON
THE ISSUES AND CERTAINLY WE'VE
BEEN WORKING TOGETHER A NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION
FOR SOME TIME I'M NOT SURE
FORTY YEARS BUT WE'VE BEEN
THERE TOGETHER WORKING ON THE
ISSUES THAT ARE THERE AND A LOT
OF TIMES- WE SEE TESTIMONY COME
BEFORE THE COMMISSION WHAT ARE
TRAVEL- MEMBERS CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL MEMBERS. WILL SAY THAT.
CERTAIN THINGS ARE ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH WITH THE BURIAL
RIGHT WITH REMAINS THAT ARE
THERE. AND REQUEST ALL THAT TO
BE- COMING BACK TO THE TO THE
TRAVEL- CALIFORNIA PEOPLE BUT
THEN DISAGREEMENT HAPPENS
BETWEEN. DEPARTMENT HEADS
ARCHAEOLOGIST- UC'S OF WHAT
THEY CONSTITUTE TO BE. NATIVE
AMERICAN- REMAINS AND THE
ASSOCIATED- GRAVES THAT GO WITH
IT AND WHEN THAT DISCUSSION
HAPPENS. USUALLY IT'S THE SIDE
OF THE UC'S IN THOSE THE END UP
PREVAILING OVER THE DISCUSSION
WITH A TRAVEL- MEMBERS THAT ARE
THERE. SO. AS THIS LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO DIVE IN TO
ADDRESSING ISSUES AND
DEFINITIONS OF GIVING THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE THE
WHERE WITH ALL TO BE ABLE TO
COME IN EQUALLY OR GREATER.
THAN THESE DEPARTMENT HEADS OR
EVEN THE UC'S RIGHT WHEN IT'S
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
REPATRIATION ITEMS WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THOSE ISSUES- YOU
BROUGHT UP AN INCLUSIVE DESK
DEFINITION. WHICH COMES BACK TO
THE WHOLE PRESENTATION FROM-
FROM MISTER STANLEY RODRIGUEZ
TO A MERRY LOPEZ KEEPER AND
CHAIRMAN HITCHCOCK INTO
YOURSELF. OF THE OVERVIEW OF
THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE%
FOCUSING STRICTLY ON. CULTURAL
RESOURCES CULTURAL PRESERVATION
AND IN INVERNESS COVERAGE OF
HUMAN REMAINS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO WE DO
LOOK AT AND WE WILL WORK
TOGETHER AND LOOK AT THE
HERITAGE COMMISSION AS BEING
ABLE TO. LOOK AT THE
INCLUSIVENESS OF THOSE
DEFINITIONS BUT IT'S BECAUSE-
OF THE INADVERTENT DISCOVERY.
THAT'S BEING DONE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
GIVING THE WAY BACK TO THE
ORIGINAL PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALL CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
THAT THOSE DISCUSSIONS OF WHAT
CONSTITUTES- REMAINS WHAT
CONSTITUTES ASSOCIATE BURIAL
GOODS WITH THEM AND WHEN THE
TRIBAL PEOPLE ELDERS ARE SAYING
ALL THIS. IS ASSOCIATED WITH IT
THEN I THINK THE WEIGHT OF THAT
SHOULD BE WITH THE TRIBAL
ELDERS. DEFINITELY AND I THINK.
THE ONE OF THE LORD ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU POINTED OUT
WHEN TRIBES- ARE TO- CONSOLE
WITH THESE INSTITUTIONS
ESPECIALLY THE ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
ARCHAEOLOGISTS OPINIONS ARE
GIVEN GREATER WEIGHT THAN THE
TRIBAL KNOWLEDGE AND THE TRIBAL
HISTORY AND SO. IT IT RELATED
TO HAVING AN INCLUSIVE
DEFINITION AND THE AND THE
PEOPLE AT THE TABLE THAT NEED
TO BE AT THE TABLE IS ALSO THE
RESPECT- AND THE INCLUSION AND
HOPEFULLY LEGISLATIVELY
MANDATED INCLUSION OF TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE- INTO THOSE DECISIONS
BECAUSE- THEY TRY TO REMOVE
FROM THE LANDS AND NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN AND LOS TIES AND LOST
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION. BUT
THEY DO HAVE INFORMATION THEY
DO HAVE PLACE NAME INFORMATION
THEY DO HAVE VALID- HISTORIES
SONGS LANGUAGE ORAL HISTORIES-
MY TRIBE WAS RECENTLY- DENIED A
CLAIM AT TO REPEAT TREAT FROM
THE PHOEBE HEARST MUSEUM AND WE
WERE TOLD THAT OUR ORAL HISTORY
WAS NICE POETRY. BUT THAT IT
WASN'T ENOUGH PROOF TO
ESTABLISH CULTURAL AFFILIATION.
AND SO THIS JUST YOU KNOW
HAPPEN AT ABOUT A YEAR AGO SO
WE'RE TALKING PRESENT DAY.
SITUATIONS AND WHERE A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBE. LOT
OF RESOURCES LAWYERS- A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT CAN HELP TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM'S BUT
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THE
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS ARE FEVER
RANG- AT THEIR SCIENTIFIC
OPINIONS OVER THE TRIBAL
KNOWLEDGE AND SO WE'RE TRYING
TO BRING A GEATER BALANCE AT
BACK INTO THOSE SITUATIONS. AND
GET THE ANCESTORS HOME- ANOTHER
PIECE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP ABOUT
THE- ABOUT THE- CLAIMS OF THE
OF THE- MOST LIKELY
DESCENDANTS- IS A CURRENT
PROJECT THAT I DON'T I MEAN I
KNOW YOUR ON THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE CAPITAL ANNEX PROJECT. AND
THAT IS ANOTHER PROJECT WHERE
WE CAN WITH THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN BE A LEADER AND
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT THE
PROPER- THAT PROCESSES ARE IN
THAT PROJECT BECAUSE THE
CAPITOL WAS BUILT PRE SYKORA-
SO THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
UNDERNEATH THE GROUND WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY RESOURCES ARE
THERE WE KNOW THERE'S GOING TO
BE THINGS THERE. WE KNOW THIS
WAS BUILT ON A FLOOD PLAIN OF
SORTS AND THERE'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE INADVERTENT
DISCOVERIES IN A LOT OF ISSUES
GOING ON HERE SO THAT'S A
THAT'S ANOTHER PIECE WHERE YOU
KNOW WE CAN BE WE CAN BE
LEADERS IN THAT ROLE OF SETTING
UP. A KEY- KEY PROCESSES THAT
CAN BE USED AS MODELS- FOR HOW
YOU CONSULT WITH TRIBES AND
INCLUDE THEM IN- IN ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE AFFECTING THEIR
CULTURAL RESOURCES. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION ALL THE PRISONERS
FOR- EDUCATING THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE AS A WHOLE.
IS OR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I HAVE
A SO MAYBE A COMMON AND A
QUESTION. I WAS AT THE UC
REGENTS MEETING WHEN I THINK IT
WAS YOUR CHAIR OF THE CHINA WHO
WHO A PRESENTED ON ON THE
PHOEBE- HERS MUSEUM AND I KNOW
THAT CHAIR- JOHN PET IS WORKING
CLOSELY CHAIR JOHN BETTIS OF
THE UC REGENTS IS WORKING
CLOSELY WITH HIM. TO TRY TO DO
BETTER. YES IN THAT ASPECT AND
I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION- IF I
MAY TO MARY I'M NOT SURE IF SHE
IF I COULD HOW HOW DOES A OF
TRIED. WHO LOSES ITS LAND. AND
NOT AND NOT FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED AS YOUR YOUR EXAMPLE
HOW HOW ARE THEY ABLE TO STAY-
YOU KNOW MAINTAIN. AT TOGETHER
AND MAINTAIN CULTURE LANGUAGE
HOW HOW DO THEY DO THAT. FIRST
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ASKING-
BECAUSE TO PERSEVERE THROUGH
EVERYTHING THEY'VE GOT WE'VE
GONE THROUGH. IT. IT BLOWS MY
MIND- TO BORROW A PHRASE FROM
THE YEAR I WAS BORN. WHAT. WHAT
MY GREAT GRANDFATHER DID NOT
LACK WAS THE. HE DID NOT SUFFER
FROM A POVERTY OF THE
IMAGINATION. HE WAS ONE WHO.
WHO FIRMLY BELIEVED THAT WE
WERE ALLOWED. OUR LAND BACK AND
HE INSTILLED IN MY ELDERS THE
FACT THAT WE ARE A PEOPLE WE
ARE A TRIBE AND WE MUST TAKE
CARE OF ONE ANOTHER AND SO WHEN
HE PASSED ON A WENT TO MY GREAT
AUNT AND MY FROM MY GREAT AUNT
IT WENT TO MY AUNT AND- A
COUSIN WHO JUST- THE LEADERSHIP
WHO ACTUALLY JUST RECENTLY
PASSED- OUR CAPTAIN WRESTLE
FROM. LAST WEEK. AND IT'S
FAMILY GATHERINGS- SO WHEN I
GREW UP I THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
WERE DOING I THOUGHT THEY WERE
JUST FAMILY PICNICS AND BUT
THEY WERE ACTUALLY TRIBAL
GATHERINGS- BECAUSE EVENING
THEN THEY WEREN'T. THEY DIDN'T
FEEL IT WAS SAFE. FOR US TO
TOTALLY KNOW EVERYTHING- WE ARE
VERY PROTECT WE ARE VERY. CLOSE
KNIT- OUR TRIBE AND- WE HAVE
ARE STORY TELLERS WHO HAD
LEARNED FROM THEIR GREAT
GRANDMOTHERS AND GRANDFATHERS
THE STORIES AND THEY WOULD
SHARE THOSE STORIES BUT BASS-
UNFORTUNATELY. A LOT OF THE
LANGUAGE. WAS LOST BUT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO REGAIN
ACKNOWLEDGE- RECAPTURE IT FREE
CLAIM IT AS OUR OWN AGAIN-
THROUGH. OUR SISTER TRIBES. AND
THEIR PROGRAMS AND IN FACT I'M
SO JEALOUS WHEN I HEAR DOCTOR
RODRIGUEZ SPEAK IN HIS NATIVE
TONGUES I'VE ACTUALLY
PERSONALLY BEEN TAKING LANGUAGE
CLASSES ONLINE. FOR OVER TWO
AND A HALF YEARS- THROUGH A
PROGRAM THAT WAS DEVELOPED BY
PITANGA. ALMOND SO I'M
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR OUR OUR
SISTER TRIBES FOR BEING ABLE TO
KEEP THAT. ONE OF THE EXCITING
PARTS ABOUT BEING CALIFORNIAN
TO IN TODAY- AS A MEMBER OF MY
OWN TRY IT IS. A LOT OF THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS SHARED BY THE
OF THE LISTEN YOU KNOW AS
THROUGH DIFFERENT
ANTHROPOLOGISTS AND
ETHNOGRAPHERS- THEY CAME BACK
FROM INFORMANTS INFORMANTS
WERE- TRIBAL PEOPLE- AT THE DAY
IN WHO NEEDED THE MONEY. TO
SURVIVE AND SO THEY WOULD SHARE
WITH THESE ETHNOGRAPHERS- WORDS
LANGUAGE HI IMPORTANT PLACES-
IN THE CULTURE- SPECIFICS
CEREMONIES WHAT THEY MEANT AND
WHAT WE'RE LEARNING IS BILLS
WERE ACTUALLY SALAS RAY.
MEMBERS AND THEY WERE SHARING
THAT INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEIR FATES
WERE GOING TO BE. BUT THEY
WANTED IT TO BE FOUND ONE DAY.
AND SO NOW IT'S SAFE FOR US TO
COME BACK AND WE CLAIM THAT
INFORMATION AND SO THAT WE CAN
BECOME STRONGER WITH IT. IT
SUCKS A STORY A FULL CIRCLE
AND- BECAUSE OF THEIR
PERSEVERANCE WE CAN CONTINUE IT
AND PROVIDE IT TO MY OWN
CHILDREN AND HOPEFULLY MY
GRANDCHILDREN. THREE BOYS SEEN
A NUMBER NOW. BUT. IT'S
DEFINITELY ONE OF THOSE
STORIES- WHERE IN ORDER FOR OUR
TRIED TO STILL BE A TRY IT
TAKES A STRONG COMMITMENT TO
ONE ANOTHER AND A BELIEF ANNA
THAT AND HOPE. THAT WE WILL.
ATTAIN WHAT IT IS THAT WAS-
TASKS- BECAUSE OUR LAND WAS
OURS FOR EVER. AND WE HAD. TO
BE FOR TO BE TAKEN AWAY THE
WEIGHT WISE AND THEN FOR US TO
STILL BE FIGHTING FOR OUR PLACE.
IT HAS TO BE ACT FIVE SORRY
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER- AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE CENTERS AND DOCTOR A
CATCHER IS IN BALI THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND
IT AND LIGHTNING. THE HISTORY
OF THIS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA PEOPLE AS
A WHOLE. AT THIS TIME WE WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. I DID WANT
TO SAY ONE THING AND THAT IS
THEM BECAUSE I WROTE ACTUALLY A
PAPER ABOUT THIS WHICH I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO LOOK INTO.
THERE WAS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION PASSED THE YEAR
BEFORE KNACK PRO WAS PASSED
FEDERALLY IN CALIFORNIA CALLED
AB TWO FIVE SEVEN SEVEN. HAS
PASSED THE TIME BY. A
LEGISLATOR HIS NAME WAS RICHARD
KATZ. IT WAS DIRECTLY TO
ENCOURAGE ANY CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION TO RETURN
INDIGENOUS HUMAN REMAINS IF
THEY RECEIVED ANY SORT OF
FUNDING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT WAS FAR MORE.
INFORMED AND ALSO HAD A LOT
MORE TEETH THAN THAT PRESS
ANYTHING AND ACTUALLY THAN THE
CURRENT CAL MAG PRESS. AND IT
ACTUALLY HAD IN IT- FINES FOR
INSTITUTIONS THAT DIDN'T
COMPLETE REPATRIATION OF THOSE
REMAINS WITHIN LIKE TEN YEARS.
AND HE ACTUALLY PASSED IT
BECAUSE AT THE TIME HE WAS
WORKING WITH CALIFORNIA INDIANS
AND HE WAS A MAN OF JEWISH
DESCENT AND HE SORT OF
UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS CONNECTION
BETWEEN THE HOUSING OF REMAINS.
AND THE HOLOCAUST AND GENOCIDE
THAT IT HAD THAT THIS HAPPENED
WAS UNACCEPTABLE AND THE BILL
PASSED IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
AND WAS GOING TO BE APPROVED IN
AT THE TIME GOVERNOR DEUKMEJIAN
VETOED IT. AND HE DID THAT
BECAUSE THE UC SYSTEM STEPPED
IN AND WROTE A SERIES OF
LETTERS SAYING THAT IT WOULD
DESTROY THE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION. IF THEY RETURN TO
THAT NUMBER OF REMAINS TO
CALIFORNIA IN PEOPLE. SO HE HAD
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
CALIFORNIANS TO DEVELOP THAT
LEGISLATION IT'S ALL STILL IN
EXISTENCE YOU CAN READ THE
WHOLE THING. THERE'S LIKE THAT
THE WHOLE THING WAS PASSED AND
THEN DID MASON VETOED IT SO I.
WOULD SAY THAT THAT LEGISLATION
ALREADY EXISTS IT WAS ALREADY
PASSED IT WAS ALREADY IN
SUPPORT LIKE THERE WAS A LOT OF
SUPPORT IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR
IT. HE WAS ONLY THE GOVERNOR AT
THE TIME THAT WE DID IT. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
OUT THERE ABOUT HOW YOU CAN
TAKE THAT AND DEVELOP
LEGISLATION THAT ACTUALLY IS
REALLY POWERFUL FOR THE RETURN
OF REMAINS- NOW. BECAUSE HE HAD
ALREADY. DONE THAT IN
CONSULTATION WITH TRIBAL GROUPS
AT THE TIME. THANK YOU OF ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. NOT
REALLY. NO WORLD REPUBLICAN
WELL CLOSE REMARKS AND I
KLEENEX NUMBER CHEN HEDRICK
SHOWING ON MY OWN MATCH A NECK
PELUK LAW GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS VIRGINIA I'M A MEMBER
THE YUROK TRIBE IN FROM THE
VILLAGE OF STRAIGHT ON AND THE
INCOMING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR
URBAN INDIAN HEALTH THE BIGGEST
PART OF MY WORK IS DOING POLICY
IN ADVOCACY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST POPULATION OF AMERICAN
INDIAN ALASKA NATIVES IN OUR
URBAN SETTINGS INCLUDING LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO SANTA BARBARA
THERE'S TEN OF THEM WE HAVE SIX
DIRECT HEALTH FACILITIES. A TO
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES- AND I DO HEALTH
HEALTH POLICY I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T MENTION THAT I GREW
UP ON A VERY REAL RESERVATION
IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY IN FACT MY PARENTS
TO GET ELECTRICITY UNTIL THE
FALL OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND STILL DO NOT HAVE PHONE
LINES ALSO I UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITY OF CALIFORNIA INDIAN
COUNTRY IN JUST THE SITUATION
THAT WE'RE IN TODAY DISCUSS ANY
UNIQUE- STATE THAT WE ARE IN
AND IN PARTICULAR HEALTH CARE
GETSVERY COMPLICATED
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST
NUMBER OF SIX THIRTY EIGHT
CONTRACTS. THAT THE INDIAN SELF
DETERMINATION CONTRACTS WITH
TRIBES OF THE INDIAN HEALTH
SERVICE WE ALSO HAVE THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF URBAN
INDIAN ORGANIZATIONS- IT'S A
THINGS GET REALLY COMPLICATED
JUST TWO YEARS AGO WE OPENED
THE INDIAN HEALTH SERVICE
OPENED ITS FIRST FEDERAL
FACILITY IN STATE AND THAT'S
THE YOUTH REGIONAL TREATMENT
FACILITY REALLY A TESTAMENT TO
A MANY OF THE THINGS THAT FOLKS
HAVE SAID HERE TODAY THAT OUR
INDIAN PEOPLE ARE IN A CRISIS-
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST RATES OF
SUICIDE AND MOST RECENTLY
WHAT'S MAKING A LOT OF NEWS IS
THAT INDIAN PEOPLE LIVING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
DYING AT RATES UP TO SIX TIMES
THAT OF OTHERS TO DO THE OPIOID
CRISIS AND WE ARE OVERDUE
OVERDOSING AT RATES THAT ARE
ASTONISHING- SO WE ARE REALLY A
HEALTHCARE CRISIS AND THERE'S
MUCH TO SAY ABOUT THAT- BUT I
THOUGHT- I DIDN'T WANT THE DAY
TO PASS WITHOUT US MENTIONING
THE VERY CRITICAL ELEMENT OF
HEALTH CARE IN THE COMPLEXITIES
FOR WHICH IS DELIVERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
THE STATE INDIAN HEALTH PROGRAM
WAS RED LINE DURING THE
RECESSION IT HAS. NOT BEEN
REFUNDED AND OUR INDIAN HEALTH
PROGRAMS OR SUFFER. AND DUE TO
THAT LOSS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORDS OF THE SPEAKERS TODAY-
IT'S HARD NOT TO SIT THERE AND
BE EMOTIONAL. BUT WE LIVE THIS
THIS IS OUR LIFE. ON AND
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR TIME TO
LISTEN TO. THANK YOU WHAT CLUB.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OTHER A PUBLIC COMMENTS.
RESPOND TO. PUBLIC COMMENT GO
AHEAD LOWER YOU HAVE A PUBLIC
COME. I JUST WANTED TO RESPOND
TO- THE COMMENT ABOUT
ASSEMBLYMAN THAN ASSEMBLYMAN
CATS LEGISLATION. M. IRONICALLY
WHEN AM I WAS AN UNDERGRAD AT
UCLA WAS WHEN I WAS GOT
INVOLVED IN REPATRIATION ISSUES
AND IT SORT OF SET THE ARC FOR
MY CAREER- AS A LAWYER AND I
WORKED WITH ASSEMBLY MAKE CATS
AS A STUDENT ACTIVISTS AT UCLA
WITH THE LOCAL- LOS ANGELES
TRIBES AT THAT TIME ON THAT
BILL AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT WHAT THE CARRIAGE
COMMISSION IS PRESENTLY LOOKING
AT- AS- UPDATING. THAT THE CAL
KNACK PRAYER IS VERY MUCH IN
LINE WITH THOSE THOSE PIECES OF
THINKING IN TERMS OF. ENABLING
TRIBES GIVING THEM THE
RESOURCES TO CLAIM THEIR
REPATRIATION AND THE MANDATES
THAT ARE GOING TO BE PUT ON THE
UC SYSTEM TO- TO GET THESE AYE
TO GET THE ANCESTORS BACK HOME
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
BEING BROUGHT UP AND WE ARE
DEFINITELY LOOKING AT THAT
THOSE SIMILAR TYPES OF
SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE PUBLIC COME IN ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. GO AHEAD
OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL
ONE OF THINGS I FORGOT TO TALK
ABOUT WITH CALIFORNIA'S OF TWO
EIGHTY STATE AND ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS WE HAVE ON A
RESERVATIONS IS THE BIGGEST
ATTITUDE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
HAS WHEN YOU KNOW ENTERING OUR
RESERVATIONS WHEN WE WHEN WE
MAKE CALLS FOR YOUR OF TROUBLE
PROBLEMS ON. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THEY PICK AND CHOOSE WHEN THEY
ARE GOING TO DO THIS HOWEVER
THEY HAVE OVERALL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS WE HAVE
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES MANY OF
OUR RESERVATIONS HAVE OF OUR
OWN POLICE FORCE SECURITY
SYSTEM. HOWEVER IT IS. IN A ONE
ONE TWO WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE SHARE
OF HAS JURISDICTION OVER
HOWEVER THEY- YOU KNOW IT'S IT
CAN BE FRUSTRATING. WHEN THEY
DECIDE THEY DON'T WANT TO COME
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE LIKE WAS OUR
RESERVATION SAN ISABELLE IT'S
OVER AN HOUR AWAY WELL ONE OF
THE MORE ISOLATED RESERVATIONS.
WE TALK ABOUT AND I THANK YOU
FOR TALKING BUT YOU KNOW HEALTH
CARE THINGS OF THAT THAT ARE
HAPPENING THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC
THAT THAT THAT'S- JUST I MEAN
DESTROYING. IN OAK FAMILIES ON
THE RESERVATIONS WE NEED TO
HAVE. WE NEED TO HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMING AND
SUPPORTING US AND HELPING US
ESPECIALLY WITH YOU KNOW WITH
PEOPLE ARE COMING IN AND
BRINGINGOPIOIDS ONTO OUR
RESERVATIONS. MOST OF MORE NON
INDIANS. YEAH AND WE I'M AND WE
DON'T SEE. THEM GETTING
PROSECUTED SO I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU BRING THOSE ISSUES-
FORWARD TO THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH AND PUBLIC SAFETY AND
RESPONSE- TO- THE TRAVEL
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE JUST HEARD-
PRESENTATIONS AND REALLY AN
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENT. OF
CALIFORNIA DID HISTORY WHEN
DEALING WITH A NATIVE AMERICAN
REMAINS HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND. WE JUST HEARD
ABOUT THE DISCONNECT BETWEEN
ARCHAEOLOGIST AND DEPARTMENT
HAS UC'S. AND TRIBAL ELDERS AND
THEIR KNOWLEDGE WHAT. WE WANT
TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT OUR
TRIBAL ELDERS AND OUR ANCESTORS
THE PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
FOR US TO BE HERE TODAY. THAT
THEIR VOICES EQUALLY A STRONG
ARE EVEN GREATER HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
THE REASON FOR THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THE HEARINGS. THAT ARE HERE TO
COLLECT THE INFORMATION SO THAT
WE COULD GO BACK. TO CREATE
LEGISLATION THAT ADDRESSES
THESE ISSUES. CERTAINLY IT'S A
IT'S A TASK THAT STARTS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE GOVERNOR-
COMING FORWARD AND HIS FORMAL
APOLOGY FOR ATROCITIES GENOCIDE
TO MOVE YOU KNOW. NOW FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE WHOLE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS IS TOUGH
BECAUSE- NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRYING TO CREATE THESE THINGS
OR TO CREATE THE HISTORY AND
MAKE SURE WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WE HAVE TO GO WAY BACK TO A
STATE THAT NEGLECTED ALL OF
THESE ISSUES IN TIME SINCE EVEN
BEFORE THE CREATION OF THE
STATE. AND SO IT'S A DAUNTING
TASK BUT WERE UP FOR AS A
SELECT COMMITTEE YOU HAD
MEMBERS COME IN AND LOOK AT IT
AND CERTAINLY WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE IN ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS THERE. AND THE NATIVE
AMERICAN HERITAGE COMMISSION IS
DOING A GREAT JOB THAT MANY
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW HAS BEEN
THEY'RE DOING THIS JOB FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS. EVEN THOSE IN THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT NOT EVEN KNOW
THAT THAT EXISTS BUT EXISTS AND
IT'S AN IMPORTANT ARE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND WITH
THAT I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR- ATTENDING THIS HEARING THE
FOR THE PANEL IN THE SPEAKERS
AND FOR THOSE OF PUBLIC COMMENT
BRINGING UP. FUTURE
DISCUSSIONS- THAT WE WILL LOOK
AT AS FAR AS HEALTHCARE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY IN THOSE ISSUES
THAT COME FORWARD. BUT ALSO I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO INVITE YOU-
TO THE CRACKER MUSEUM. TO AN
EXHIBIT THAT'S BEEN THERE SINCE
SEPTEMBER. AND. ITS TITLE WHEN
I REMEMBER SHE READ. AND WE
HEARD THE DISCUSSIONS HERE
TODAY AND WE HEARD SOME OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AS FAR AS IT
IT'S TOUGH FOR. PEOPLE TO HEAR
WHAT'S GOING ON IN ME EVEN AS
THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
THE FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT UC BERKELEY
HAVING SO MANY REMAINSTILL IN
THEIR ARCHIVES. THE THAT HAS TO
AFFECT YOU SOMEHOW. RIGHT AND
SO. I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
JOIN US- AND WE PUT OUT FLYERS.
TO JOIN US AT THE CROCKER
MUSEUM STARTING AT FIVE THIRTY-
TO TOUR THE EXHIBIT- WHEN I
REMEMBER I SEE RED AND THIS IS
NATIVE ARTISTS. THEM THROUGHOUT
INDIAN COMMUNITY. PUTTING ON
CANVAS PUTTING AN ART. WHAT IS
WHAT IS GOING ON IN INDIAN
COUNTRY TODAY I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU OFFER FOR ATTENDING
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. FOR
BEING HERE WITH US AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU AT THE
CROCKER MUSEUM. DOORS WILL OPEN
AT FIVE THIRTY AND WILL BE
THERE- TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE AND TO TOUR- THE CRACKER
MUSEUM IN THIS EXHIBIT. THANK
YOU FOR ATTENDING